Almost heaven, older Twitch chat, all these emotes, wondering how to spell that.
Now we're all ones moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitch emotes, from long ago, made you feel, you're not alone.
Apple-Pock-Champ, people for help, Twitch emotes, I remember, typing dance game, swift rage, chase salt and fail fish.
Ammo-Box-Camp war ja, ich seh es.
Hi Happen, 911, Simona, Dankeschön, huge, higher Q-Sub.
De Franke, Z.
Das war Wende.
Jetzt will auch keiner mehr, ey.
Frankessi, Frankessi.
De Franke, Z.
Ah, Windows hat sich's gemerkt, immerhin.
Einmal die Sound-Settings, aber wobei, 100%ig ist es immer noch nicht, ne?
Eigentlich, you miss, fail.
Oh, what's...
Moin, Pan, Timbo, excellent.
Huge.
Ah, ja.
Gibt's eigentlich noch mehr so ordentliche Twitch-Songs, die nicht total geisteskrank sind?
Die meisten Twitch-Songs sind ziemlich dämlich, so dass der Twitch-Chat drauf abgehen kann.
Oder Twitch-Chat, außer mein Twitch-Chat natürlich.
Das sind nicht die hellsten Leuchten.
Das Excusili, ne?
Das ist das Excusili.
Das meine ich zum Beispiel.
Das ist mit Sicherheit total hängengeblieben.
Tribulon, sieben Monate.
Huge.
Hi, IQ-Sub.
Dankeschön.
Bisschen lauter.
Hier gibt's nur Exquisite-Talk.
So sieht's aus.
Chat, ich muss euch nochmal refreshen, weil ich sonst nix sehe in meiner Vorschau.
So, jetzt, jetzt.
Ich war's.
Alles wunderbar.
Pepe-Hands-All-Chat.
Ja.
Man muss, man muss aber Twitch echt mal zugucken.
Man muss Twitch mal zugutehalten, wenn man sich das mal anguckt, ja?
Ich hab mal so Exe, ich muss mal kurz Pause machen, sonst höre ich mich selbst.
Also, man muss ja Twitch mal zugutehalten, dass im Vergleich zu YouTube, die ja gerade so 2014, 15 rum, die Plattform teilweise komplett unbenutzbar gemacht haben mit Sachen, die teilweise bis heute noch drin sind.
Wie zum Beispiel, dass es keine gescheite Inbox mehr gibt.
Ähm.
Dass du nicht mehr gescheit Kommentare wieder findest, Endless-Scroll und solche Geschichte.
Muss man sagen, also, alles in allem ist Twitch immer noch ganz gut benutzbar.
Also, an Twitch, Twitch hat sich eigentlich fast nur, also, reden wir mal nur von der technischen Seite, ja, ja.
Also, seit der Amazon-Übernahme hat sich die Technik von Twitch eigentlich fast nur verbessert.
Natürlich sind mehr G-Bait-Sachen reingekommen, ja, das Scam-Train ist am Start, du kannst jetzt Bits, wobei Bits gab's, glaube ich, vorher auch schon.
Oder Cheers, ich weiß nicht mehr, ein paar Sachen gab's vorher auch schon, aber die haben das Ganze natürlich auch gebaut, aber das Drop-System und so, natürlich gehört das alles dazu, um so die View-Time hochzuschrauben, aber das ist ja irgendwo auch okay.
Ähm, so, und im Gegensatz zu YouTube, was halt irgendwie immer weiter unbenutzbar geworden ist, ist Twitch wirklich ganz okay, kann man nix sagen.
Fertig geworden mit der Türöffnung, ich sag, ja, ja, das funktioniert ja schon die ganze Zeit.
Äh, was ich machen wollte, ist, ich wollte, dass man das ordentlich über, über, ähm, übers WLAN updaten kann.
Und da hab ich heute Morgen noch ein bisschen dran rumgeschraubt, aber da hatte ich keinen Bock, ja.
Ich mach danach irgendwann weiter.
Weil ich muss heute, ich muss heute ein paar Sachen noch machen, ich wollte heute noch ein Video aufnehmen.
Zu diesem Valorant Anti-Cheat, Valorant, Valorant, wir haben ja gestern gelernt, wie man das ausspricht.
Anti-Cheat.
Ähm, ich muss noch zu meinem YouTube-Netzwerk.
Schicken, weil wir das bis spätestens zum 20. brauchen.
Steuer, Krempel.
Und, äh, ich muss jetzt erst nochmal hier, war jetzt noch ein paar Stunden streben, so.
Der Kommentator ist auch am Start.
Bei Twitch gab's auch mal ne Inbox, ja, stimmt, stimmt, ist die weg?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ist die weg?
Twitch.
Inbox, es gab mal ne Inbox, richtig.
Twitch, Inbox, ist die Inbox, ist die, ist die weg?
Die ist tatsächlich weg, ja.
Die Twitch-Inbox ist weg.
Das ist natürlich ziemlich doof.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die ganzen, äh, Streaming-Seiten so scharf drauf sind, Social-Funktionen, äh, die man halt auch ordentlich verwenden kann, auszubauen und nur Social-Funktionen einzubauen.
Ich sag, erinnert sich noch irgendjemand an, kennt das noch jemand?
Kennt den Schwachsinn noch jemand hier, wo ist es denn?
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Kennt den Blödsinn noch jemand?
Da haben mir die Leute wirklich gedacht, wenn sie rumspammen, dann gibt's kein Google+.
Das war natürlich Google.
Vollkommen egal.
Und heute ist Google+, RIP.
Gibt's Google+, eigentlich, zumindest von den Seiten her noch?
Hehehe, ja.
Gibt's die Google+, gibt's die Google+, Pages eigentlich noch, Google+, oder ist Google+, mittlerweile, komplett, RIP?
Ich glaub, Google+, ich glaub, Google+, ist wohl komplett RIP, ha?
Ja, anscheinend.
It's social, it's bold, it's fun.
And it looks...
Die schreiben einen Stumpfsinn.
Die schreiben einen Stumpfsinn, Alter.
Nein, ich stimme nicht zu, aber was soll ich machen?
And it looks good.
Also, wenn eine Sache Google+, nicht gemacht hat, dann ist es gut ausgeschaut.
Ja.
Das sah aus, wie irgendein Material-Design-Zeug von Google, was selbst, wie sie selbst nicht wussten, wie sie den einen Kram machen sollen.
Also, Google+, sah nicht gut aus.
Und fun war es definitiv auch nicht.
Es war entzwungener Scheiß, war Google+.
Google+, war absolut entzwungener Scheiß.
Und das geht mir bis heute noch auf den Sack, was sie da gemacht haben, damals.
Das ist der Zeitpunkt, wo die Usability von Google komplett für den Arsch war.
Also, so ein typisches Kack-Google-Produkt, mit vielleicht einer guten Idee an manchen Stellen, aber die Umsetzung voll für den Arsch.
Ich hab das Gefühl, Google-Produkte und Software ist das, was früher bei Sony teilweise am Start war.
Nur auf ganz anderer Ebene.
Sony hat ja auch immer richtig gute Hardware gebaut, aber wer sich beispielsweise mal die PS3 in der ursprünglichen Fassung angeguckt hat,
sowohl für Entwickler, als eben auch von der Usability-Oberfläche und wie hakelig alles war.
So kommen mir auch immer die ganzen neuen Google-Produkte vor.
Nur, dass Google halt bei vielen Sachen so gar nicht optional ist.
Du hast gar keine andere Chance, als den Kram zu verwenden.
Oder es halt versucht, komplett links liegen zu lassen.
So.
Wir gucken jetzt...
Wir gucken am Anfang.
Mal eine Runde.
Weil das immer ganz gut ist zum Einstieg.
Wir gucken mal eine Runde Battlefield.
Long Range Sniper Plays.
Kannst du dir mal das neue iPhone SE anschauen?
Oh ja!
Gibt's das schon?
Wann wurde das vorgestellt, das Neue?
Hatten die gestern irgendeine Präsentation, oder was?
Hatten die gestern irgendeine Präsentation, oder so?
Hab ich das übersehen?
Warum vergesse ich das immer?
Ich muss mir sowas in meinen Kalender eintragen,
weil dann restream ich das und
und lässt da ein bisschen über Apple ab dabei.
Ja, die Seite unseres Vertrauens.
Wir gucken uns einen Chip.
Was war denn denn?
Was waren vor ein paar Tagen?
Apple...
Was gab's denn da?
Apple Spring Announcement.
Oder was war das?
Achso, es war nur eine Pressemitteilung.
Okay.
Apple Events 2020.
Gucken wir mal, was es da gibt.
Ja, Monka Corona schlägt da auch zu.
Was machen eigentlich
so die Corona-Zahlen
in den USA so?
Was geht da gerade?
Boah!
Fuck, Alter!
Die kriegen das ab, ey!
Hat die USA
mittlerweile so viele Corona-Zahlen
wie die restliche Welt zusammen?
Das könnte fast irgendwie...
Nicht ganz,
aber fast.
200, 400...
Nicht ganz.
Aber bald haben die
so viel Corona wie die restliche Welt
zusammen.
Wobei man halt sagen muss,
den Chinesen glaube ich das
nicht so ganz.
Ich habe letztens irgendeinen Bericht gelesen,
dass in China wieder das Militär
anrücken musste und Leichen abtransportieren
machen sie in Italien auch.
Also, wie weit
die Zahlen aus China stimmen, ist sehr fragwürdig.
Beim Valorant
Anti-Cheat wurde wohl ein Pro gebannt,
weil er sein Handy am PC geladen hat.
Echt? Hast du da mal einen Link zu?
Sehr lustig.
Ja, so ist das halt mit Anti-Cheat.
Ich habe gestern ein bisschen Deathran
geguckt und der wurde auch einmal wegen Anti-Cheat
gekickt.
Hast du schon das Video von
Y-Collective
über Hacker gesehen?
Nee. Taugt das?
Okay, was?
Hacker.
Welches? Welches Video ist das?
Das da?
Okay, bevor ich sowas
gucke.
Bevor ich sowas gucke.
Ist das
ein ordentliches Video oder ist das, dass man sich permanent
cringe fremd schämen muss?
Cringe? Oh fuck.
Okay.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns das
Hardcore cringe.
Okay, ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns das wirklich
jetzt ganz am Anfang angegeben sollen.
Ich muss erstmal meinen Chatlogger wieder
einschalten.
Auf dem Level von dem IT-Interview.
Was war denn das IT-Interview nochmal?
Ach das!
Oh ja, oh Gott, das war
cringe, ja.
Das IT-Interview war cringe, das stimmt.
Äh.
Wo ist mein Meme-Board?
Wo ist
mein P-Pega-Board?
Hier.
Wo habe ich es nochmal hingelegt?
Irgendwie, das hatte so
einen komischen Ordner, war das.
Net3, genau, das war
Huge Big Brain Benahmung war das
wieder von mir.
So, das war P-Pega-Board launchen.
Was irgendwie nicht geht, warum nicht?
Ah, yes, excellent.
IP leaked.
Äh, erstmal
Ich hoffe, ich habe gestern alles beantwortet.
Weil ich werde jetzt einfach mal
gerade loslöschen
von gestern die Fragen.
Ich vermute mal, ich habe alles beantwortet.
Ich gucke ja immer viel Chat.
Krasses Aim.
Key Pass oder Last Pass?
Key Pass, eindeutig.
Aha.
CS GoPro Mixwell wrongful
bent by my...
After Plugin in Phone.
Oh ja, das ist ja, also
ein Smartphone anschließend an den Rechner,
das ist ja schon fast Cheaten.
Hahaha, Lust.
Das ist ja geil.
Und jetzt da wird der Endband.
Consistently Evolving Detection Method.
Ah ja, das...
Ja, das ist schon scheiße, ne?
Das suckt schon mal hardcore.
Gut, also.
Dann gucken wir jetzt mal zuerst.
Also,
mit was
mit was wollen wir anfangen?
Wollen wir mit dem Cringe Hacker Video anfangen
oder wollen wir uns eine Runde Battlefield Top
Sniper Plays angucken?
Was halten wir
am Anfang jetzt erstmal am besten?
Okay.
Wenn ihr wollt, wenn ihr wollt,
ja.
Okay, es geht ja schon gut los,
Alter.
Bisschen lauter.
Oh.
Was?
Exposed.
Das bin ich.
Er macht Cash mit gehackten Kreditkartendaten
aus dem Darknet.
Wie häufig hast du da jetzt eingekauft?
Also, ich würde schon meinen mindestens 100 Mal.
100 Kreditkarten? Ja.
Ich will wissen, wie leicht man mich hacken kann.
Krasser Hacksaw aus dem...
aus irgendeiner komischen
über Tor erreichbaren Dings sich da
Kreditkarten kaufen.
Wahnsinnig krasser Hacksaw.
Da ist ja einiges möglich.
Ich muss nochmal aufpassen jetzt genau.
Also, wer kann die SMS ansehen?
Die Anrufe?
Alles so, was du so tippst?
Wo du gerade bist?
Ja.
TempCounter, da bin ich voll dabei. TempCounter ist schon mal eine sehr gute Variablen-Benahmung.
Victims, hohoho. Label4, na das ist die Default-Benahmung vom Windows Forms Designer.
Stimmt, eigentlich, SilverDark hat recht, eigentlich müsste es, es muss ja KebabCase,
ne, nicht KebabCase, äh, was ist das, CamelCase. Temp und Counter groß, das ist,
hier, Csharp.net Guidelines violated. Anzeige ist raus. KebabCase, na KebabCase ist das mit dem
Minus dazwischen. KöftespießCase, kann man sich tatsächlich besser merken mit dem Minus
dazwischen. Victims, okay, man erkennt, man erkennt nicht wirklich, was es, was es macht,
außer eine Datei lesen und einmal, einmal Counten für jede, für jede Zeile, das ist
ganz schön umständlich, aber okay.
Ähm, dann machen wir Victims und dann gibt es ein String-Array für den Victims,
hier mal für den Counten, was auch immer, macht das irgendwas Sinnvolles. Append Text,
okay, die geben irgendwelche, irgendwelche Sachen, wahrscheinlich analysieren sie irgendwelche
CSV-Files oder keine Ahnung, irgendwas. Ne, das ist, das ist glaube ich nicht, das
glaube ich, das könnte Java sein, äh, ich glaube aber eher, es ist .net. Das sieht mal
ganz, das sieht, das sieht eher, das sieht eher nach Csharp aus. Das könnte Java sein,
aber, äh.
Aber die Namen und, äh, Bezeichnungen sehen mir auch, diese Two-String, die sehen mir
zu, zu .net-ig aus und auch die String-Reader, Stream-Reader-Geschichte, das und die Try-Catch-Geschichte,
das und, und dass es Visual Studio, äh, ähm, dass es Visual Studio ist, das ist, ähm,
ziemlich sicher Csharp.
Das sind für mich eigentlich Menschen, die irgendwie alles können, sozusagen wie die
Herrscher des Internets. Ein ganz großer Teil der Bevölkerung hat glaube ich keinen
Plan, was die machen und wie die das machen, ähm, und ein ganz kleiner Teil kann damit
zum Beispiel Unternehmen ruinieren. Deshalb frage ich mich in diesem, äh.
Naja, ich, soll ich einfach mal was spoilern? Viele Hacksore haben manchmal auch keine Ahnung,
warum die Sache funktioniert. Nein, also, später schon, aber es ist oftmals so, ähm, ohne
das jetzt, ne, ich möchte mir jetzt ja hier nicht den Anschein geben, als bin ich der
krasse, der krasse Hackerman, aber ich mein, man kennt's von normalem Programmieren, man
macht was und denkt sich, scheiße, warum funktioniert das? Oder umgedreht auch, scheiße, warum funktioniert
das jetzt nicht? Und bei beiden sitzt man so vorm Rechner und denkt sich, warum ist das
jetzt so?
Und das ist da garantiert genauso. Habe ich euch schon erzählt, um am, um auch mal eine
krasse Hacksore-Story von mir jetzt zum Besten zu geben, dass ich mir eine Überwachungskamera
gekauft habe, vor drei Jahren oder so, und rausbekommen habe, dass man total easy das
Root-Passwort auslesen kann von dem Ding, per Curl, man muss einfach einen Curl-Aufruf
machen und dann spuckt das Ding das Root-Passwort aus. Also ein unauthentifizierter Curl-Passwort
an die Kamera schicken, an die richtige, an die richtige Url mit dem richtigen Payload
gibt, ähm, das Root-Passwort von der Kamera aus. Ähm, hab ich vor, hab ich vor zwei, drei
Jahren rausgekriegt. Ja, hab ich, hab ich. Ähm, und zwar, ursprüngliche Frage war, also
warum, warum ich da überhaupt drauf gekommen bin, ist, ähm, ich hab mir eine Überwachungskamera
gekauft und hab ne, ne Software, ich glaub TinyCam auf Android war das, hab ich die Kamera
eingerichtet und, ähm, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab,
ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab. Und die
Kamera konnte auf einmal, die konnte auf einmal ein Vorschaubild anzeigen. Und ich
dachte mir, wie zum Geier kann die Software ein Vorschaubild anzeigen, ohne dass ich meine
Benutzerdaten eingegeben hab. Ich sag, wie geht das? So, und dann hab ich mal ein bisschen
geforscht und hab mal ein bisschen Ports gescannt, was auf ist, ein paar, paar, paar Curl-Requests
geschickt und irgendwann bin ich dann draufgekommen, wenn man an die richtige, an die richtige
Url von der Kamera den richtigen Curl-Request schickt, kriegt man ne Antwort mit dem, mit
den, mit den Login-Daten für den, für den Stream, was gleichzeitig auch das Root-Passwort
ist.
Und da habe ich im Internet mal ein bisschen geguckt, also nach diesem Root-Passwort.
Und das ist eine Sicherheitslücke, die gibt es wohl schon seit Jahren in diesem China-Bord, China-Chip, den diese Kamera verwendet.
Das ist schon wohl uralt.
Also hätte man schon längst fixen können.
Das war irgendwie gefühlt 10 Jahre alt, der Backe war halt noch immer in der Kamera drin.
Und das habe ich dem, ich habe es so gemacht, ich habe auf GitHub, auf GitHub unlisted GIST hochgeladen, eine Anleitung, wie das geht.
Und habe das an den Typ, an den Hersteller geschrieben.
Das habe ich das nicht damals sogar im Stream gezeigt sogar?
Das habe ich sogar im Stream gezeigt damals.
Und zumindest hat er es erst nicht kapiert, was ich wollte.
So irgendwie, hä?
Wie, was, wie, guck mal hier, da im Handbuch steht es.
Da habe ich gesagt, nee, nee, Leute, ich kriege das Root-Passwort mit einem Kölner.
Dann hat er es gecheckt.
Und das Erste, was er geschrieben hat, ist, ob ich nicht auf GitHub die Seite runternehmen kann.
Das hat ihm nicht gefallen.
Das war ihre größte Sorge erst mal, dass ich die GitHub-Seite lösche.
Zumindest, tatsächlich, sie haben sich darum gekümmert.
Und irgendwie ein halbes Jahr hat ewig gedauert.
Ein halbes Jahr später habe ich eine Mail gekriegt.
Es gibt jetzt eine neue, updated Firmware, die das Problem fixt.
Ich habe es aber nicht ausprobiert, ob es das Problem fixt.
Ich habe mich mit diesem Bug nicht weiter beschäftigt bisher.
Und ich habe die Kamera auch nicht im Einsatz.
Naja, was auch immer.
Wir gucken mal, so viel zu meinen krassen Hacker-Stories.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal die richtigen Hacker an.
Die machen und wie die das machen.
Und ein ganz kleiner Teil kann da...
Irgendwie guckt er übelst leidend, oder?
Der guckt, er hat Schmerzen irgendwie.
Cute Chat.
Kio-Kun ist am Start.
Zehn Monate in Folge.
Ja, ja, ja.
Welche Text-to-Speech-Software verwendest du für Nice?
Du meinst das hier.
Das ist gar keine Text-to-Speech-Software zum Installieren.
Das ist irgendein koreanischer Text-to-Speech-Webservice.
Ich weiß aus dem Kopf nicht...
Nicht mehr, wie der heißt.
Müsste ich gleich mal irgendwie Source-Code-mäßig nachgucken.
Aber es gibt nicht so viele.
Such mal...
Ich glaube, das war in den japanischen oder koreanischen Text-to-Speech-Service.
Da musste man sich erstmal registrieren auf einer koreanischen Seite.
Ich habe viele Fake-Daten damals registriert mit Google Translator für die Seite,
da ich sie überhaupt verstanden habe.
Und das war der beste Text-to-Speech-Service für Weep-Text-to-Speech.
Get rekt.
Das ist hier...
Keine andere Software hat so eine nice Text-to-Speech-Funktion wie meine, ja.
Easy.
Ja, die klingt richtig Weep-mäßig.
Deswegen habe ich die auch genommen.
So, weiter.
Der guckt wirklich so, als hätte er schon mehr Herzen.
...zum Beispiel Unternehmen ruinieren.
Deshalb frage ich mich in diesem Film,
wie viel Macht haben Hacker wirklich?
Sieh lautstärke, okay?
Hamburger Hauptbahnhof.
Oder bin sie lauter?
Hier wird mit zwei Typen verabredet, die McDonalds gehackt haben.
Oh, McDonalds.
Hi, na?
David, rechts im Bild ist 23.
Das kann schon mal nicht sein.
Also erstens, dass sie sich bei helllichtem Tag treffen
und dann noch nicht mal Sonnenbrille und Kapuzenpulli aufhaben.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das können keine echten Hacker sein.
Litschak, 1978, sechs Monate, Dankeschön, HiIQ-Sub.
Mosenik, auch neun Monate am Start, huge.
Subscriber.
So, ich muss gucken, ob ich keine Subs übersehen habe.
Nee, habe ich nicht übersehen.
Fake-Doku, siehste?
Keine Hacker, keine Hacker.
Ohne Kapuzenpulli, Sonnenbrille und im Dunkeln können das keine Hacker sein.
Lenny ist 20.
Wie alle im Film jünger als ich, habe ich so auch noch nicht gehabt.
Beide sind Programmierer und haben sich durch ihren McDonalds-Hack kennengelernt.
Und kommt ihr jetzt direkt von der Arbeit, oder was?
Ja.
Ich habe es mal gemacht.
Ah, frei bekommen, nice.
Unabhängig voneinander haben sie beide eine Sicherheitslücke im Bestellsystem entdeckt,
die weltweit funktioniert.
Ihren Hack haben sie dem Unternehmen gemeldet und zur Belohnung eine goldene Karte bekommen.
Oh, Leute, der Scam-Train ist am Start.
Habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
94 Prozent, dass der Scam-Hype-Train läuft.
Der will euch gebeten.
Ja.
Ihr habt es geschafft.
Krass.
Endlich habe ich die auch mal in der Hand.
Fast Food for Free für ein halbes Jahr.
Ach, nur ein halbes Jahr?
Okay.
Das ist ja eher eine Strafe.
Das ist ja eher eine Strafe, weil dann hast du im Hinterkopf immer das Gefühl,
Alter, ich muss jetzt ein halbes Jahr möglichst viel Fast Food fressen.
Das ist echt problematisch.
Das ist ungesund ohne Ende wahrscheinlich.
Wenn die sagen würden, okay, keine Ahnung, für zehn Jahre,
dann hast du nicht so den Drang dahinter.
Fuck, ich muss jetzt jeden Tag zu McDonalds und die leer fressen, dass es sich lohnt.
True.
Keck weh.
Genau.
Ich hatte unendlich viele Getränke-Codes zu erstellen, beziehungsweise zu generieren,
weil da auf einer Seite eine Abfrage gefehlt hat.
Ich konnte kostenlos Essen bestellen, konnte alle Artikel auf 0 Euro setzen
und dafür habe ich dann auch die Karte gekauft.
Dann lasst uns...
Haben die da im Backend keinen Plausibilitäts-Check?
Was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Haben die da nicht irgendeinen Plausibilitäts-Check so nach dem Motto,
hat zehn Burger bestellt?
Frage.
Bestellung kleiner fünf Euro.
Ist da vielleicht irgendwas verkehrt?
... uns doch erstmal reingehen und mal was bestellen.
Der Provokateur hat den Hype Train getraint.
Was auch immer.
Dankeschön.
Vier Monate SUP.
Huge.
Um nichts zu sagen, ein.
Colin Vortex sagt, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie das nicht haben,
wenn man sich anschaut, wie die App programmiert wurde.
Okay.
Bin ich angeschaut.
Ich auch.
Dr.
Entvie.
Oh, jetzt sind wir sogar schon Level 2 beim Scam Train.
Dankeschön für den SUP.
David schenkt das Essen einem Obdachlosen.
Das ist nicht gestellt, das macht er öfter.
Ist ihm wichtig, dass ich das hier sage.
Ja.
Vielen lieben Dank.
Bitte.
Und dann wünsche ich noch alles Gute.
Gleichfalls.
Ja, danke ebenso.
Ciao.
Nette Hexer.
Hackern unterscheiden sich in ihren Absichten.
Es gibt die White Hats, die nur legal und im Auftrag hacken.
Black Hats, die ihre Fähigkeiten kriminell ausnutzen.
Und Grey Hats, die sich im Graubereich bewegen.
Zu denen zählen sich die meisten.
Spielt ein Green Hat.
Auch Eddie und David.
Also es kommt halt wirklich auf die Person an, wie sie mit sowas umgeht.
Ob sie jetzt, sag ich mal, Böses im Sinn haben.
Dann können sie viel Schaden machen.
Und halt die Guten, die helfen halt, sag ich mal, gegenseitig.
Oh, die Gespräche tun schon so ein bisschen weh.
Bekämpfen sie einfach.
Genau.
Wir sind ein Cute Hat.
Lenny nimmt uns mit zu sich nach Hause.
Er wohnt bei seinen Eltern unterm Dach.
Ja, hier.
Drei Bildschirme.
Ja, natürlich.
Gaming Chair.
Hier hat er sich das Hacken beigebracht.
Nicht über eine Google-Suche, sondern indem er erst mal Programmiersprachen gelernt hat.
Hacken zu können ist das eine.
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Programmiersprachen zu lernen, anstatt über Google zu suchen, wie lerne ich Hacken.
Das ist nicht blöd.
Aber ohne Erlaubnis in ein fremdes System einzudringen, finde ich Morale schon fragwürdig.
Das Ganze ist ja eigentlich wie ein Einbruch, oder wie würdet ihr das?
Eindringen kann man schon sagen.
Ja, es kommt auf die Lücke drauf.
Ja, es war schon eingedrungen.
Das, was wir jetzt bei McDonalds gefunden haben, das war jetzt nicht wirklich einbrechen.
Das war eher eine Lücke, um, sag ich mal, selber was kostenlos zu bekommen.
Aber es ist nicht wirklich jetzt Datenklau oder sowas.
Meistens gehen sie aber den legalen Weg.
Über die Plattform HackerOne bekommen sie ihre Jobs.
Das funktioniert so.
Unternehmen wie Starbucks, Spotify, Paypal oder Lufthansa bieten an, finden eine Lücke
und kassieren eine Prämie.
Da hat Lenny schon hier und da ein paar hundert Euro verdient.
Ein paar hundert Euro.
Kann man gutes Taschengeld nennen, ja.
Also man könnte es auch hauptberuflich sowas machen, aber da müsste man wirklich den ganzen
Tag am PC sitzen und konzentriert dabei bleiben.
Und ich habe nicht so eine Ausdauer dafür, für sowas.
Die richtig guten, die richtig lukrativen Sachen, da ist es ja auch nicht mit einfach
mal ein bisschen Kleinzeit JavaScript editieren oder eine Android-App.
Sich angucken getan.
Ziemlich viel für nebenbei.
Da muss man halt auch richtig was drauf haben und selbst die Leute, die richtig was drauf
haben, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass die beiden keine Ahnung haben, ich kenne sie nicht,
selbst die finden ja auch nicht laufend was.
So die richtig lukrativen Sachen, wo man nicht nur 100 Euro kriegt.
... noch das Geld aus ihren Hauptjobs in IT-Unternehmen.
Und wie sie eine Lücke austesten, zeigen sie mir jetzt bei einem Lieferdienst an.
Bei einem Lieferdienstanbieter.
Oh Knärbär, huge, huge skill.
Was, 10 Euro, ist das denen hier in Ernst?
Bei Amazon?
Das ist ja armselig.
Und was zum, was zum?
Bei einem Lieferdienstanbieter.
Ah, das ist das Formular auf der Webseite.
Ja gut, die haben es halt, das ist so, also es hat ohne Scheiß.
Die Anbieter, die kleinseitig diese Checks machen und backendmäßig nichts überprüfen,
die sind selber dran schuld.
Das hat mit, mit, mit, mit irgendwie krassem Hacksaw nichts zu tun.
Das kann ja jeder machen.
Im, äh, in den Developer Tools, in, in, in Firefox und Chrome.
Also das sind einfach, ja, oder sag mal so, es ist schon irgendwo, ne, das war gehackt,
aber, ähm, da sind die Anbieter nur wirklich selber dran schuld.
Ich, und ich wette mit euch, wenn man, äh, bei Dönerläden bestellt oder bei irgendwie,
irgendwelchen anderen lokalen Läden, die es halt vielleicht nicht über Lieferando machen oder sowas,
du wirst wahrscheinlich laufend so Dinger finden.
Kann man eigentlich hier einfach auf Null setzen.
Das ist jetzt, bei dieser Seite ist das jetzt ziemlich einfach so.
Auf, bei McDonalds war das jetzt nicht so leicht, einfach den Preis auf Null setzen.
China House.
Bei dieser, äh, bei dieser Seite ist es einfach.
Man drückt einfach auf Forward.
Und jetzt ist dieser Artikel.
Ja.
Mit Null Euro hier drin.
Ja, die Frage ist nur, die Frage ist nur, ob das akzeptiert wird, ne.
Also ich mein, ich kann ja kleinseitig viel einstellen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ja, ich kann kleinseitig alles einstellen, was ich will.
Die Frage ist, ob die Gegenseite das auch ausführt.
Das ist ja der eigentliche Knackpunkt.
Scheiß.
Ja.
Krass.
Und, aber das funktioniert wirklich?
Also wenn du jetzt.
Ja, also hier ist sechs Euro Mindestbestellwert.
Aber wenn ich jetzt, wenn es keinen Mindestbestellwert gäbe, könnte ich jetzt einmal bestellen.
Oder ich füge noch einen Artikel hinzu für 6,50.
Und dann könnte ich jetzt diesen Artikel kosten.
Ja, wenn du jetzt, mach mal spaßeshalber einfach so ein paar Artikel einfach hinzufügen.
Ja, das ist ja eine Rückstellung.
Sieht zwar einfach aus.
Das ist, das kannst du auf jeder Seite machen.
Das kannst du auf absolut jeder Seite machen.
Da ist nichts, das hat noch nichts mit dem Backend vom Anbieter zu tun.
Das, das geht überall.
Ob es dann angenommen wird, ist halt die Frage.
Mach aus.
Aber bis man so eine Lücke gefunden hat, kann es dauern und braucht es Erfahrung.
Ähnlich wie bei McDonalds wird die Bestellung abgefangen.
Ja.
Dann wird die Lücke verändert, also der Preis auf Null gesetzt und erst dann zum Restaurant geschickt.
Macht das süchtig?
Und das Restaurant ist dämlich, wenn die das nicht checken.
Ich denke schon, oder?
Also es gibt einen Dopaminausschuss, wenn man eine Sicherheitslücke findet.
Ein Dopaminausschuss?
Ich kann mir das selbst irgendwie nicht erklären.
Das ist bei mir mittlerweile so, dass ich immer noch Sicherheitslücken brauche.
Ja, Boss FTV, das ist ein guter, ein guter, gutes Beispiel.
Ich kann mich auch bei der Bank einloggen und dort meinen Kontostand auf eine Million stellen.
Dadurch habe ich auf dem Konto immer noch nicht eine Million, sondern rein bei mir im Browser steht halt eine Million.
Also überhaupt, macht überhaupt nichts außer Anzeige bei mir lokal.
Okay und inwiefern, was fühlt man da oder woher kommt dieser Dopaminausstoß?
Keine Ahnung, wenn man etwas gefunden hat, dann ist man glücklich.
Und man ist froh, dass man das geschafft hat.
Wir machen das jetzt auch mal.
Ich will jetzt auch mal krasser Hexer sein.
Lieferan...
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Lieferando tatsächlich was dagegen gemacht hat, dass man so einfach im Webinterface Zeug manipulieren kann.
Okay, Lieferservers in Frankfurt.
So.
Log.
Zwar Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt.
Easy.
So, was gibt es da zu Essen zu bestellen?
Was haben wir da?
Korle-Pizza.
Korle-Stellen-Pizza.
Salami-Pizza.
Easy as fuck.
Jawoll.
Hinzufügen 6,90.
Jetzt.
Achtung, Leute.
Huge Hack.
OMG.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Also, da wird es kritisch langsam.
Da wird es kritisch.
Heckermann Conference.
Und so etwas Besonderes, sage ich mal, er gefunden hat, was andere nicht geschafft haben.
Diese Lücke, die sie mir hier zeigen, funktioniert bei 6.500 Lieferdiensten, die auf dieser Seite hinterlegt sind.
6.500 Lieferdienste.
Viele Website-Betreiber sind ja selbstständige Leute, die eine Familie haben.
Also, wie gesagt, bei mir hätte das jetzt nicht funktioniert.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass das bei Ihnen funktioniert.
Die Frage ist halt, ob das der Anbieter, wenn er diesen Request kriegt, checkt, ob das funktioniert.
Ob das plausibel ist, was du ihm geschickt hast.
Und die logische Variante, wie man sowas vorbeugen kann, aus Anbietersicht, ist ganz einfach.
Man nimmt einfach überhaupt keine Informationen aus dem Frontend, außer was derjenige bestellt hat.
Also sprich, du nimmst jetzt, okay, der Typ, der hat Artikel mit Nummer 512 und mit Nummer 815, mit ID 815 bestellt.
Du kannst vielleicht sagen, okay.
Du kannst vielleicht überprüfen, ob der Preis, den du bei dir gespeichert hast, mit dem Preis, den er dir schickt, übereinstimmt.
Ansonsten kannst du eine Fehlermeldung anzeigen.
Aber dann guckst du einfach bei dir in der Datenbank da nach, okay, was kostet Artikel 815 und Artikel 512.
Und das rechnest du dann ab über PayPal.
Leitest das weiter und nimmst da nichts aus dem Frontend entgegen.
Aber es kann durchaus sein, wie gesagt, ich will nicht sagen, dass das nicht stimmt, was du hier erzählst.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Dass es genug Seiten gibt, die das eben nicht überprüfen.
Und das ist halt, das ist halt Fail.
Wie krass gehackt das jetzt ist, kann man sich drüber streiten.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall bescheuert vom Anbieter.
Richtig beknackt.
Jon331 abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Oh je.
Leute, es geht los.
Ei, ei, ei.
Habe ich Subs vergessen zu erwähnen?
Muss ich gerade mal schnell drüber scrollen.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Zum Glück.
Der Provokateur, 4 Monate.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dich erwähnt habe.
Aber Dankeschön für den Sub.
LeChuck19786 Monate.
Dankeschön.
Wie ich die Subs, die Subs alle nicht sehe.
Und mal hier gucken.
Musenik, 9 Monate.
Dich hatte ich glaube ich schon.
Aber trotzdem noch ein Dankeschön für den Sub.
Wohnung zahlen müssen.
Habe ich euch, habe ich euch übrigens schon gesagt, was ihr tolles machen könnt, wenn ihr ein Amazon Prime Abo habt?
Da könnt ihr kostenlos auf Twitch einen Streamer eurer Meinung machen.
Einen Streamer eurer Wahl.
Subscriben.
Das kostet euch nichts zusätzlich.
Einfach seinen Amazon Prime mit Twitch Prime verbinden.
An solchen Leuten schade.
Ich meine, man ist ja solchen Leuten ja nie persönlich begegnet.
Dann ruiniert man ja sein Leben.
Wenn seine Website ja nicht mehr funktioniert.
Er keine Einnahmen mehr hat.
Kann er seine Familie nicht mehr versorgen.
Er kann seine Wohnung nicht bezahlen.
Und warum sollte man es solchen Leuten schwer machen, so.
Bei mir ist es eher die Moral, die mich davon abhält, böse Sachen zu machen.
Ob das wirklich funktioniert?
Wir bestellen drei Pizzen für 6,60 Euro zur Selbstabholung.
Den Mindestbestellwert können die beiden nicht umgehen.
Ja, dann los geht's.
Ich treffe Max, so nenne ich ihn.
Irgendwo in Brandenburg.
Na zur Selbstabholung ist schon, ist schon, dann ist ja da irgendeiner an der Kasse und nimmt das Geld entgegen.
Das, das ist, das ist schon komplizierter.
Das musst du, das musst du eventuell schon abrechnen lassen online, dass keiner checkt.
Alles easy, dass es nicht war.
Ja nice, dass es heute geklappt hat.
Ja gerne.
Er will unerkannt bleiben, weil er ein krimineller Hacker ist.
Oh.
Ein Black Hat.
Er ist 20, hat schon mit 13 angefangen zu programmieren.
Krimineller Hacker.
Heute nutzt er seine Skills für Cybercrime.
Laut Bundeskriminalamt sind etwa die Hälfte der Tatverdächtigen in der Cyberkriminalität unter 30.
Also das hier ist zum Beispiel ein DOS.
Also das ist eine Angriffsmethode.
Schau wieder.
Also die ganzen Hacker verwenden gerne Visual Studio, wie es aussieht.
... der Alarm legen kann.
Und die habe ich hier selber programmiert.
Das ist eine bestimmte Technik, die ich dort verwende.
Die nennt man die Shotgun-Technik.
Oh.
Shotgun bedeutet, er simuliert 1000 Aufrufe einer Website, die den Server überlasten.
So ist der Internetauftritt vorübergehend nicht...
Okay, zeig mal her.
... erreichbar.
Ah.
Das gibt's, das gab's doch früher schon.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Iron Cannon, Low Orbit Cannon oder so.
Dieses komische Uraldedos-Tool.
Warte mal, wie hieß das Kram?
Irgendwie so, ne?
Ah, genau.
Ist es das?
Das ist es nicht, aber es ist was ähnliches.
Es ist was ähnliches.
Ist anscheinend was ähnliches.
Also ich meine, da auf Go zu drücken...
... ähm...
... ist jetzt keine große Kunst, ja?
Okay, zeig mal her, ich will mal gucken, was haben wir da?
Die, den Server.
Können wir das, können wir das so ein bisschen in scharf?
Okay, jetzt erkennt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt erkennt man es halbwegs.
Bot Explode DOS.
Okay, das ist das Benutzerinterface.
Das ist das Benutzer, das, das ist das, das GUI von dem Ding.
Und im Prinzip macht er einen neuen Thread auf und schickt einen neuen Request oder irgendwie sowas wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das ist jetzt keine große Hackerkunst.
... war überlastend.
So ist der Internetauftritt vorübergehend nicht erreichbar.
Also das halte ich ja mal für ein Gerücht, wenn das gescheit gemacht ist, ähm...
... dass du das damit von einem Rechner daheim hinkriegst.
Da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ich meine, früher ging das relativ easy.
Da hast du einfach, äh, hast du zwei Varianten, waren da, waren da relativ beliebt.
Ähm, wo es heute, wo es heute ein bisschen schwieriger ist.
Äh, also zwei Sachen waren früher relativ beliebt und die, die man auch, äh, ohne Probleme von daheim, von daheim machen konnte.
Das erste war sowas hier.
Wenn es euch genau interessiert, könnt ihr euch das ja mal bei Wikipedia angucken.
Du tust einfach so, als willst du eine Verbindung zum Server aufbauen und baust keine Verbindung zum Server auf.
Du schickst einfach ganz viele Anfragen zum Server.
Ähm, zum Server sagst du, ich will Verbindung aufbauen, will Verbindung aufbauen, will Verbindung aufbauen, will Verbindung...
Das kostet dich so gut wie nichts und den Server kostet es relativ viel Speicher.
Weil da musst du ja eine komplette Verbindung aufmachen, musst den ganzen Kram im Speicher halten, bis der Timemode oben ist.
So, also das ging, ähm, das ging früher relativ gut und das konntest du auch von daheim machen.
So, äh, das ist eine Sache, die, äh, also das funktioniert halt prinzipiell immer noch.
Allerdings, ähm, beugen die meisten Webserver mittlerweile vor, indem sie Verbindungen mehrfach benutzen.
Ähm, so, und das zweite, was auch relativ beliebt war, war, ähm, ähm, oh, wie heißt das?
Amplification? Gibt's da auch einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu?
Genau, das, das war auch eine Sache, die war eine Zeit lang relativ beliebt.
Da hast du, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das richtig zusammenkriege, da hast du einen DNS, ähm, da hast du eine DNS-Anfrage gestellt an einen DNS-Server.
Allerdings hast du gleich eine DNS-Anfrage gestellt an einen DNS-Server.
Allerdings hast du, glaube ich, den Absender gefaked, sodass quasi die Antwort von den DNS-Servern zurück zu dem Typ ging, den du lahmlegen wolltest.
So, das war, das war so die, äh, die Idee bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Also sprich, sagen wir mal, ich hab den Google-DNS, ich, sagen wir mal, ich hab ganz viele DNS-Server voll gespammt mit Fake-Abfragen.
Und ich hab gesagt, meine, ähm, ich bin, ich bin der, der Absender XY und XY ist halt das, was ich lahmlegen will.
Und XY ist halt das, was ich lahmlegen will.
Und dann hab ich DNS-Abfragen geschickt an ganz viele DNS-Server halt mit Absender ichbinServiceXY.
Und die Anfragen an den DNS-Server zu schicken, die sind relativ klein und easy.
Allerdings ist die Antwort von dem DNS-Server relativ groß.
Das heißt, ich kann von daheim mit einer, mit einer, äh, ziemlich, ähm, schmalbrüstigen Leitung ganz viele DNS-Anfragen an ganz viele verschiedene DNS-Server schicken.
Und ähm, die DNS-Server antworten dann aber mit einer recht großen, mit einer recht lauten DNS-Seite.
einer recht großen, mit recht viel
Daten an den Typ, den ich
angreifen oder den ich lahmlegen will.
Das sind so die zwei Basic
Dinger, die früher ganz gut funktioniert haben.
Ich würde mal sagen, spätestens wenn man
Cloudflare davor hat,
hat sich die ganze Sache
eh erledigt. Das geht immer noch.
Ja, geht beides prinzipiell
immer noch.
Sunfloat geht schlecht, weil
viele Server jetzt einfach
Verbindungen re-usen,
wenn es ab einer gewissen Anzahl
genau,
das ist das, was viele Web-Server machen.
Achso, nach dem Video
noch das neue iPhone, genau,
hab ich ganz vergessen. Gucken wir uns
gleich an.
Ja, so viel
zu dem krassen Hack-Sort-Zeug.
Das ist kein wahnsinnig High-IQ-Hack,
sowas zu machen.
Das kann jeder mit dem passenden Tool.
Oder auch,
im Prinzip kriegt man das wahrscheinlich,
habe ich nie probiert, aber wahrscheinlich kriegt man das auch
mit einem Curl
und Bash und einer
Wildschleife irgendwie hin.
Oder Netcat. Netcat und eine
Bash-Wildschleife. Wahrscheinlich kriegt man das damit auch
irgendwie gebacken.
So, ähm,
zählen wir mal das Hack-Sort-Video weiter.
Hast du Tipps, wie man programmieren lernen kann?
Na, das Beste ist, wenn du irgendein
spezielles Problem hast, was du lösen willst
und dann suchst du dir
die passende Technik dafür raus, mit der du das Problem
am besten lösen kannst. Also wenn du jetzt
zum Beispiel sagst, ich würde gerne eine
Windows-Desktop-Anwendung programmieren,
weil ich
äh, was könnte man da haben wollen,
immer aktuelles
Wetter von meiner Wetterstation anzeigen
will, könnte ja sein, und
angenommen, da gibt es noch keine Software dafür,
dann würdest du am besten anfangen mit
erst natürlich unter Windows und würdest dir
wahrscheinlich .NET bzw.
Sharp angucken für Windows-Desktop-Anwendungen.
Ja, und mit Desktop-Frameworks
ist es ein bisschen schwierig, da weiß ja Microsoft
selbst nicht so genau, was Sache ist.
Was macht eigentlich, muss ich gerade mal kurz
gucken, was macht denn eigentlich das hier?
Gibt es da eigentlich jetzt schon eine Beta-Version von?
Gibt es da jetzt schon die Desktop-Variante
für Win32 für?
Aha.
Was? .NET Core not support?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Okay, das ist noch absolut unfertig. Gut.
Weil das ist, das wird das neue
Windows-UI-Framework, was sie endlich mal länger
unterstützen wollen.
Ist der eine Typ nicht bei dem Hacker wie der YouTuber
Gar Collim?
Keine Ahnung, sagt mir, sagt mir nix.
Was ist, was ist Gar Collim, Lüm?
Weiß ich nicht, sagt mir nix.
Okay, gucken wir erst mal weiter.
Dass er mir das hier zeigen kann, ist mit dem
Betreiber der Website abgesprochen.
Sieht gewaltig aus, ihn hält aber einem digitalen
Taschenspieler-Trick wie mehr ein Sprecher vom Chaos-Computer-Club sagt und funktioniert
nicht bei allen Webseiten.
So, da haben wir's.
Dann sieht das so aus.
Das ging jetzt relativ schnell.
Das hat, was hat das gedauert?
Zwei Sekunden, würde ich meinen.
Und das bedeutet, die Website ist jetzt außer Gefecht.
Die kannst du nicht mehr aufrufen.
Genau.
Also, wenn ihr möchtet, wir können das nochmal über Handy probieren, dann könnt
ihr auch mal aufrufen.
Ob die Website jetzt wirklich down ist, checke ich mit dem Handy, denn das ist nicht mit
seinem Netzwerk verbunden.
Und hattest du in der Hinsicht schon...
Richtiger Hacker.
Also Aufträge?
Richtiger Hacker-Man, ja.
Über gewisse Telegram-Gruppen, wo sich quasi Leute treffen, die sich dafür interessieren.
Also, wer für sowas wirklich jemand braucht, zu beauftragen, dann weiß ich auch nicht, ja.
Äh, dort gestern halt sowas wie, guck mal, ob das geht.
Und wenn es geklappt hat, dann hat man öfter drüber geredet, okay, pass mal auf, ich geb
dir hier vielleicht ein bisschen Geld im Sinne von Bitcoin-Überweisungen oder halt anderen
Kryptowährungen.
Ich frage ihn, was ihn daran reizt.
Und das ist auch das Tolle, was mich daran so reizt, man ist halt wirklich nicht irgendwie
gebunden...
Aber hat einen ordentlichen...
Ach nee, doch nicht.
Ich dachte, es ist ein Thinkpad, ist es nicht.
...gebunden, bestehende Systeme weiterzuentwickeln, sondern du kannst wirklich halt deine eigenen
Wünsche so verwirklichen.
Also, egal, was man sich denkt.
Man kann im Endeffekt...
Man kann im Endeffekt alles lösen.
Das ist einfach...
Nein, kann man nicht.
ETF.
Wie soll man...
Wenn man alles lösen könnte, dann hätten Seiten, die Authentifizierung und Login anbieten,
echt Probleme.
Das ist extrem wahnsinnig.
Ob er wirklich alles lösen kann, weiß ich natürlich nicht.
Als nächstes zeigt er mir Marktplätze mit Benutzerdaten.
Quasi, also man kennt das ja, man ist am PC und drückt auf Passwort speichern.
Ja.
Und quasi dieser Account beinhaltet diese kompletten Logindaten für Google Office
Netflix, Zalando...
Ja, aber nicht, weil ich Passwort speichern geklickt habe.
ETF.
Nicht, weil ich...
Nein!
Warum sollte das da auftauchen?
Weil ich in meinem Browser...
Was, ein Schwachsinn?
...Facebook.
Und da hättest du überall Zugriff.
Genau.
Wenn du jetzt hier 18 Dollar ausgeben würdest.
Diese Daten auszunutzen...
Das kommt eher daher, weil die Leute sich irgendeinen Keylogger oder irgendwelche Rootkidstrojaner-Geschiss
eingefangen haben.
Tatsache.
Ja.
Oder sich eingefangen haben, teilweise vielleicht ihre Festplatte weggeschmissen haben, nicht
gelöscht haben oder halt sich selbst zu dämlich angestellt haben, im Klartext irgendwo Passwörter
gepostet haben und und und.
Das kommt nicht einfach, weil ich im Browser auf Passwort speichern drücke.
Wenn ich im Firefox einfach sage, hier, Formular Passwort speichern, taucht das nicht auf einmal
irgendwo über Tor in irgendeiner Börse auf zum Passwort kaufen.
The fuck?
Das ist aber gar nicht so einfach, weil man ähnliche technische Parameter braucht wie
der Originalbesitzer.
Zum Beispiel die IP-Adresse oder die Bildschirmauflösung.
Deshalb verkauft er einzelne Login-Daten in Telegram-Gruppen weiter.
Das macht er auch mit Kreditkarten-Daten.
Das hat ja mit Hacken absolut nichts zu tun, ne?
Das ist einfach krimineller Shit im Endeffekt, wenn man es so will.
Ich meine, es kann jeder sich über einen Tor-Browser oder sonst wo auf irgendeine Darknet-Verkaufe-XY-Seite
begeben.
Dort den Kram kaufen.
Und dann über irgendwelche Telegram-Gruppen weiterverkaufen.
Das ist so wie ein Klopapier-Großhändler oder so.
Da kann er auch was verkaufen.
Wirklich, gehackt ist das jetzt nicht.
Da braucht man nur die nötige kriminelle Energie dafür.
Man muss sich wahrscheinlich geil genug finden, dass man keine Gedanken hat, daran verschwendet,
was ist, wenn man erwischt wird.
Weil ich glaube nicht, dass man mit diesem Resellen jetzt die Wahnsinns-Kohle macht, weil
die, die es im großen Stil haben wollen, die gehen einfach direkt dahin und kaufen sich's.
Das heißt, man resellt das an irgendwelche anderen kleinen Kriminelle, vermute ich jetzt
mal.
Das heißt, so wahnsinnig viel Kohle will man damit nicht machen.
Wenn man erwischt wird, bist du halt im Arsch.
Also, eigentlich ist es eher blöd und hat mit Hacken nichts zu tun.
...die er im Darknet kauft.
Drei Viertel der Polizei bekannten Straftaten im Internet sind Vermögens- und Fälschungsdelikte,
so wie diese.
Ich mache jetzt hier zum Beispiel mal eine Kreditkarte aus Potsdam.
Ja.
Ach, so bekommst du die?
Genau, so als Textdatei.
Hat er jetzt, hat er jetzt wirklich sein Notepad fünf Sekunden gebraucht, bis es aufgeht?
Jetzt hier gespeichert, das hier oben, das ist aus dem Darknet gekauft.
Diese...
McCaim, fünf Monate lang, schön.
Huge.
Was, da hat er ICQ?
Ernsthaft?
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken.
Na gut, ICQ gehört doch jetzt den Russen.
Ja.
ICQ gehört doch jetzt den Russen.
Die sind da bestimmt voll dabei.
Wir machen jetzt krasses einzelne Frames, einzelne Frames zurückspulen, Leute.
Ich will ICQ auf dem Desktop sehen.
Ja.
Ey, boah, fuck, Alter, echt.
CC-Cleaner.
Ah.
Irgendwelches Android-Zeug.
Raster kenn ich nicht.
Aber allein schon, allein schon, dass die alle Windows verwenden, was ist mit denen
los?
Kann man gedrückt halten.
Oh, doch, tatsächlich.
Ich hätte länger gedrückt halten müssen.
Oben ist das aus dem Darknet gekauft.
Diese...
Genau.
Also die obere, also quasi nur...
Das ist nicht CSV, das ist, ähm, Pipe-SV.
PSV ist das, Pipe-SV.
Du hast das aus dem Darknet gekauft?
Hast du das ausgenutzt?
Moin, Patrick.
Zehn Monate, dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Also quasi...
High-IQ-Sub.
Wir haben die gekauft, die ist dann halt einfach schon verbraucht.
Wie häufig hast du Darknet gekauft?
Wie häufig hast du da jetzt eingekauft?
Schwer zu sagen, also oftmals, ähm, also ich würde schon meinen, mindestens hundert
Mal.
Hundert Kreditkarten?
Ja.
Damit der Besitzer...
Kann jeder machen, der genug, die, der die genug kriminelle Energie hat.
...davor nichts mitbekommt, muss Max noch einen Dollar fünfzig ausgeben.
Dann flucht ich die E-Mail-Adresse, kriegt einer tausend Mails, hat einfach den, die
Schlussfolgerung, der guckt morgens auf sein Handy, denkt sich, was ist denn hier los und
drückt auf alles löschen.
Alle Benachrichtigungen.
Und somit geht diese ganze...
Ja.
...Kreditkarten-Benachrichtigung komplett unter.
Weil es ist oftmals so, dass zum Beispiel, ähm...
Können wir das mal machen?
Ja.
Hast du eine Karte, wo...
...der, wo du das mal machen könntest?
Also wir tragen jetzt hier quasi auf dem Portal die E-Mail-Adresse ein.
Ja.
Dann einfach nur eine Testbeschreibung, wie viel ich jetzt hier machen möchte, mindestens
das siebenhundert.
Ja.
Das kostet...
Also das heißt, siebenhundert...
Mails.
...Mails kommen da jetzt an.
Genau.
Also natürlich...
Ja und?
...meldet das Programm die Mail-Adresse bei siebenhundert Newslettern an.
Ja super.
Ich kann Spam verschicken über einen Service, der mich Spam verschicken lässt.
Ja.
...Adresse haben wir extra für diesen Test erstellt.
Wenn man das jetzt aufs Handy kriegt, dann dreht man durch.
Hm.
Dann kann es halt...
Wer kriegt auch Notifications für E-Mails auf das Handy?
Hat irgendjemand Notifications für E-Mails an?
...vibriert.
Das ist auch einfach nur nervig.
Echt?
Alter Leute, was ist mit euch los?
Oh Gott.
Chat.
Hilfe.
Ich habe keine Notifications für E-Mails.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil ich den Account von der Arbeit drauf habe.
Den Mail-Account von der Arbeit.
Da wird dann laufend gespammt.
Also gespammt von...
Also keine Spam-Mails, sondern laufend irgendwelche Status-Mails und sonst was.
Das ist nicht schön.
Und tun dir da die Leute nicht leid, die dahinter den Karten stecken?
Ich sag mal so, dadurch, dass ich sie ja wirklich wieder erstattet bekomme von der Bank.
Nicht.
Weil...
Ich sag mal so.
Wenn man jetzt einer Privatperson schaden würde, das wäre nicht gut.
Aber dadurch, dass man ja quasi einem großen Unternehmen schadet, ist es halt noch mit
der Moral zu vereinbaren.
Muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Weil...
Warum schadet er keinen Privatpersonen, wenn er da irgendwelche Accounts und Kreditkartengarten
von privaten Leuten kauft?
Was ist das für eine Erklärung?
Wir sind Verbrecher und so.
Da gibt es für mich dann keine Moral.
So denkt er.
Argumentiert mit der Moral, vergisst aber, dass der Kreditkartenbetrug eine Straftat ist.
Ich hätte eigentlich auch gerne eine Hackerin getroffen.
Aber es gibt nur sehr wenige und keine wollte mit mir reden.
Hacker grills.
Dafür aber der begehrteste Auftragshacker, wie es in einigen Branchenmagazinen heißt.
Ist besetzt oder wie?
Ja, ist besetzt.
Hat mich, glaube ich, weggedrückt.
Ja, mal abwarten.
Was jetzt, wann er hier ankommt.
Ich meine, wir sind da.
Mal sehen, wann er da ist.
Ah, da bist du ja schon.
Alles gut?
Ja, und selber?
Wart ihr das?
Ne, wir haben gedacht...
Ist das jetzt ein echter Hexer?
Zur Abwechslung mal?
Du kommst...
So?
Können wir machen.
Er heißt Philipp, ist 19 und hat ein eigenes Unternehmen für Cybersecurity in Hamburg.
Etwa 20 Leute arbeiten regelmäßig.
Okay, dann das sollte jetzt mal wirklich jemand sein, der Ahnung hat.
Anscheinend.
Ist hier auch dein Büro?
Ihr müsstet mir den Gefangenen diesen Empfang nicht so filmen.
Das wäre so die Grundvoraussetzung.
Als wir reinkommen, gibt's erstmal klare Ansagen und einen Geheimhaltungsvertrag zum Unterzeichnen.
Unterschrieben.
Erstmal NDA in your face.
Im Forbes-Ranking ist er unter die Top 30 unter 30 gewählt worden.
Durfte jetzt sogar einen AT.
Ich bin bei dem Artikel in irgendeinem komischen Hotel eingeschlafen und das war tatsächlich
eine krasse Erfahrung.
Das habe ich...
Ich durfte noch nie einen Artikel schreiben.
Philipp ist White-Hat-Hacker, heißt er hackt nur...
Von wann ist denn das Zeug bitteschön?
Ich durfte noch nie einen Artikel schreiben.
146G-Sassplan.
Ist ja Antik.
Ich meine, die sind in der Regel immer ein bisschen kleiner, aber die sind schon ganz
schön alt.
Philipp ist White-Hat-Hacker, heißt er hackt nur im Auftrag von großen Kunden wie Banken
oder Energieversorgern.
Oder von mir.
Auf was davon könntest du jetzt einfach so zugreifen?
Also das Problem an so einem iPhone ist halt, das ist an sich recht sicher, wenn es einigermaßen
neu ist und folglich auch noch die Softwareunterstützung aufweist.
Einmal weil das vom Konzept her nicht unglaublich große Angriffsvektoren bietet.
Bedeutet, iPhones können nur geprüfte Software aus dem App-Store laden.
Android-Geräte hingegen können auch aus den Browser-Apps installiert werden.
Android, das ist halt der Vor- und Nachteil davon.
Deswegen verwende ich für mein Heim-Automatisierungs-Zeug nur Android-Tablets.
Und so zum Benutzen habe ich mein ganz normales iPhone.
Du kannst halt automatisierungsmäßig und bastelmäßig unter Android deutlich mehr machen.
...die mit einer Schadsoftware infiziert sein können.
Sind wir mal ganz ehrlich, es ist um einiges leichter, das Telefon einfach nur zu klauen.
Oder dich dazu zu zwingen, dass du dieses Passwort eingehst, damit ich an deine Nacktbilder
komme oder was auch immer, als mich in dein Telefon zu hacken.
Das ist für den Großteil der Bevölkerung nicht möglich.
Aber ich habe z.B. gelesen, man kann ja heutzutage auch, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Tools kaufen
oder man kann...
Genau. Die Dinge, wovon wir immer lesen, dass ganz viele im Instagram-Accounts gagged worden sind,
dahinter steckt meistens nicht diverse Einzelpersonen, die die Motivation haben, an spezielle Dinge
von bestimmten Personen zu kommen.
Das stimmt. Da hat er recht.
Das mag sicherlich bei Prominenten der Fall sein.
Und die Instagram-Authentifizierung hat mit sicherlich auch keine Schwachstellen, weil sonst wären es auf einmal ein paar Millionen Accounts.
Das sind Leute, die sich irgendwas eingefangen haben, lokal, sei es irgendwelche Keylogger, oder nicht aufgepasst haben.
Im Grundsatz ist es so, da sind irgendwelche Bots oder Personen mit Tools oder eben auch ohne.
Also da sind Personen, die Interesse haben, einfach mal dort eine Sicherheitslücke zu finden, um nicht an einen spezifischen Account zu kommen,
sondern in dem Fall an Millionen Accounts.
Ja.
Die haben vielleicht ein wirtschaftliches Interesse.
Solche Bots oder Tools probieren Listen von häufigen Passwörtern durch.
Das und Phishing-Angriffe sind meistens Grund für gehackte Accounts.
Regnet es eigentlich?
Es ist super, finde ich.
Im Fokus seiner Arbeit stehen aber gar nicht Privatpersonen.
Er kümmert sich darum, dass Unternehmen nicht angegriffen werden können.
Risikoprävention.
Also Fehler in Prozessen zu finden, die potenzielle Angreifer ausnutzen.
Zum Beispiel, indem sie vertrauliche Daten abfangen, fremde Systeme steuern oder Schadsoftware wie zum Beispiel Trojaner einschleusen können.
Hier an seinem Lieblingsort sprechen wir über das, was ihm im Moment am wichtigsten ist.
Sein Job.
Wenn man Dinge schützen möchte, dann muss man präventiv alle Möglichkeiten eruieren und im besten Fall auch Präventivmaßnahmen dafür schaffen.
Derjenige, der es aber versucht anzugreifen, muss nur eine Verwundbarkeit finden.
Und meine Kernkompetenz besteht darin, frische Insights zu generieren, Dinge in Frage zu stellen und mal unkonventionelle Ansätze zu haben.
Für das andere habe ich gute Kollegen, die über mehr Berufserfahrung verfügen, vielleicht auch noch den akademischen Wegwand haben und die notwendigen Zertifizierungen dafür aufweisen.
Es gibt Hacksaw-Zertifizierungen?
Greifbar werden sowohl er als auch seine Tätigkeit für mich nicht.
Er wirkt auf mich sehr bedacht, er agiert sehr vorsichtig.
Ihn wurmt jedenfalls, dass er mich nicht ausspionieren konnte und er lädt mich nicht aus.
Das ist eine große Herausforderung für mich.
Das ist eine große Herausforderung für mich. Er wirkt auf mich sehr bedacht, er agiert sehr vorsichtig.
Er schreibt mich nochmal ein.
Philipp zeigt mir eine neue Angriffsmethode starting where das perfide dabei nicht sein soll .
Dasjest keine Ahnung, dass China jetzt eine Tätigkeit für empresas, die sich nicht drucken lassen.
Der Hacker ist oft ein Partner oder eine Person, die dir nahe steht.
Du brauchst direkten Zugriff auf Smartphone um die Software zu installieren.
Das gibt es in gin denn.
Ja, das, was ganz viele unterschätzen ist,
Ganz vieler hat vollkommen recht.
Dass man eben von innen da irgendetwas machen sollte ist nicht ausgesprochen.
Das ist ganz ernst.
Ist nicht ausgeschlossen, aber die Chance, dass sie irgendeinen haben, der in dem Unternehmen arbeitet oder, ich sag jetzt mal ganz billig gesagt, bei dir irgendwie, äh, keine Ahnung, putzt oder sonst was, die Chancen sind deutlich höher, als dass da von außen irgendein unbekannter Dinger treibt.
200 verschiedene, die zwischen 20 und 200 Dollar kosten.
Ein eingeschleuster Trojaner mit Schadsoftware.
Man sieht schon mal daran, dass das wirklich ein echter Hexer ist, weil er ein ordentliches Betriebssystem verwendet.
... sammelt und zum Ausspionieren bereitstellt.
Aber der, das ist ja nicht mal das, was ich gepostet hab, sondern der hat ja einfach alles mitgeschmissen.
Der hat einfach alles mitgeschmissen.
Leute, wir haben's gestern gelernt, was für ein Betriebssystem benutzt er?
Nicht Valorant, sondern, sondern, ah, fuck, wo ging der Scheiß nochmal?
Online-Reader.
Ubuntu.
Genau.
Sieht zumindest so aus.
Sieht zumindest so aus, wie der steile Ubuntu.
Es könnte aber auch ohne Probleme, es könnte aber auch ohne Probleme irgendein x-beliebiges anderes, äh, was weiß ich,
wenn es ein richtiger Hexer ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein Kali oder ein Tails oder sowas.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, es sieht, es sieht mit diesem App-Drawer links halt einfach aus wie ein Ubuntu, muss aber nicht.
Ich mein, mittlerweile ist ein ganz normales Gnome drauf.
Es kann auch durchaus, äh, guck, lesezeichen, ah, es ist ein Kali-Linux.
Es ist kein Ubuntu, Leute, ich hab Mist erzählt.
Es ist, es ist ein Kali-Linux.
Dann ist, also, man sieht schon, das ist zum ersten Mal der erste richtige Hexer, den wir hier sehen.
Im Video.
Alles, was du in die Tastatur...
Jetzt mal WhatsApp.
Okay, wenn du dich das traust.
Was hab ich da?
Ja, okay, das ist jetzt nichts Wildes, so, ne?
Aber im Prinzip, du könntest alles mitlesen.
Ja, alles, was du mittippst, sozusagen.
Hä?
Ich will den Kommentar gar nicht sehen, da ist einfach nur so eine geschlossene Klammer.
Ja, weil ich dann wahrscheinlich vergessen hab, irgendeinen Smiley zu beenden.
Aber das ist ja auch das, was...
Wer ist Lenny?
Lenny ist der, den wir heute gefilmt haben.
Ah, okay, guck mal, jetzt kommen die Schnipsel zusammen.
Aber das heißt ja...
Krass, dann, also, dann wird...
Also, auch das, was ich nicht abschicke.
Ich find die Fotos ganz interessant.
Das war aus einem privaten Video.
Das ist ein Video-Chat heute, das ist...
Brauchst du dich, dass wir da mal draufklicken?
Können wir gerne machen.
Da wär rot.
Nee, ach, mir macht das nix.
Ach so, was ich mir mal...
Ach, guck mal, das sieht doch sympathisch aus.
Oh Gott.
Das sieht doch ganz sympathisch aus.
Immerhin kotzt du da gerade nicht.
Der Markt für Stalkingware wächst stark.
Der Antiviren-Software-Hersteller...
So wirklich, man muss halt sagen, so richtig krasses Gehexor ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Das sind halt fertige Sachen, die sie irgendwie bei ihm aufs Handy...
...eingeschleust haben.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gedacht, wir sehen jetzt ja mal so die richtigen Hackermans.
...registrierte von 2018 auf 2019 einen Zuwachs um 77%.
Deutschland ist europäischer Spitzenreiter.
Ist ja einiges möglich.
Also, wir können die SMS ansehen, die Anrufe.
Alles so, was du so tippst.
Wo du gerade bist.
Ja.
Der Support sagt, ohne Zugriff aufs Gerät lässt sich die Software nicht aufspielen.
Philipp sagt mir...
...es geht doch durch das Ausnutzen von Schwachstellen, kostet aber viel Arbeit.
Empfehlung vom Software-Support...
...Smartphones kaufen, die den Trojaner bereits vorinstalliert haben, falls kein Zugriff besteht.
Wollen wir das mal deinstallieren?
Ja.
Jetzt ist echt genug mit der Spielerei.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich hoffe mal, danach hat er erstmal eine Runde sein iPhone gesettet.
Falls er das verwendet.
Ob das jetzt wirklich weg ist?
Ob sie wirklich weg ist, das können wir ja hier sehen.
Ob der jetzt noch weiter drauf zugeht.
Also technisch...
Ja, und wie kriege ich das hier komplett weg?
Dass ich gar keinen Zugriff mehr darauf habe.
Also technisch könnte es natürlich sein, dass sie jetzt einfach bloß nicht mehr angezeigt wird.
Und dass du über dieses Panel keinen Zugriff mehr hast.
Aber die Daten vielleicht dennoch abfließen.
Keine Ahnung.
Er lässt mich mitten im unguten Gefühl und offenen Fragen zurück.
Und auch bei Max habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich noch nicht alles weiß.
Ich frage mich, womit macht er hauptsächlich sein Geld?
Er zeigt mir Telegram-Gruppen, über die er Methoden zum Hacking verkauft.
Moment.
Das zensieren sie das da aber nicht.
Was verdienst du da so?
Also wie gesagt, damals zu Hochzeiten, das war circa vor zwölf Monaten, wo das so richtig gut mal lief.
Da waren das schon so 2.000, 3.000 Euro im Monat.
Wer kauft denn sowas über Telegram?
Methoden verkaufen.
Andere prahlen wiederum in den Gruppen und zeigen ihren vermeintlichen Verdienst.
Dadurch, dass er anderen Hacking-Methoden beibringt,
sorgt er dafür, dass die 87.000 Fälle von Cyber-Crime im engeren Sinne mehr werden.
Würdest du eigentlich sagen, Hacken ist bedrohlich?
Also natürlich wird es irgendwann bedrohlich, wenn die Entwicklung auch gerade so weit hingeht,
von Menschen auch, dass alles nur noch digital gemacht wird.
Weil man ist ja dann im Endeffekt extrem angreifbar.
Und Sicherheitslücken gibt es immer.
Die wird es auch immer geben.
Mit David und Lenny will ich jetzt die bestellten Pizzen abholen.
Und wir schauen, wie der Pizzadienst auf die Rechnung reagiert.
Und dann das.
In dem Geschäft ist jetzt ein Fahrradladen.
Vielleicht umgezogen?
Wir rufen die angegebene Nummer an.
Moment, wurde der Scammer da gerade gescampt?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Haben die jetzt 6,50 bezahlt, ohne dass sie eine Pizza kriegen?
Nein, geht ran.
Zumindest wollen wir den Seitenbetreiber über die Sicherheitslücke aufklären.
Denn es sind ja 6.500 Lieferdienste betroffen.
Hallo Lenny, mein Name, wir haben bei euch eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden,
die es ermöglicht, kostenlos zu bestellen.
Und wollten die einmal melden, dass die behoben wird.
Ja, fangen Sie ganz kurz an.
Ja.
Ich bin nämlich gerade tatsächlich einkaufen.
Haben Sie die Möglichkeit, mir das einmal aufzuzeigen
oder zu empfinden im Video oder was auch immer?
Ja, ich kann Ihnen sonst eine Mail schicken, da wo dann alles drinsteht.
Das wäre super.
Der Unternehmer ist überrumpelt.
Reagiert aber positiv.
Denn den beiden ist es auch schon vorgekommen,
dass das Gegenüber in so einem Fall...
Äh, Chicken Wookie, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, huge sub.
...Anwalt gedroht hat.
Entwickeln Sie zufällig Webseiten oder sowas?
Ja, eigentlich schon, ja.
Ja? Eigentlich schon, dann schicken Sie mal Ihren Link mit dazu.
Jackpot.
Vielleicht springt er ja jetzt auch noch einen Job für Sie raus.
In diesem Fall hatte Ihre gute Absicht Erfolg.
Na dann.
Wichtig ist zu differenzieren.
Hacken heißt nicht gleich böse Absichten zu haben.
Ich finde es erstaunlich, was die Hacker, die ich treffen konnte, so drauf hatten.
Aber ich habe auch gelernt, ein Hacker kann nicht alle Lücken kennen,
sondern nur einen Bruchteil.
Unbegrenzte Macht, so mein Eindruck, hat keiner.
Aber ich bin überrascht, wie leicht man an Daten kommt.
Darum, je vernetzter unser Leben wird, umso mehr Angriffslücken wird es geben.
Dieses Risiko sollte sich jeder bewusst sein.
Wichtig war und ist mir,
dass durch meine Recherche zu dem Thema niemand geschädigt wurde.
Also der einzige...
Oh, es geht noch einer.
...Recherche auch manchmal Angst von Hackern,
gehackt zu werden.
Weil ihnen vielleicht nicht passt, was ich für eine Reportage mache.
Aber inzwischen weiß ich ja, so einfach ist das gar nicht.
Vielleicht kann man mich nicht hacken.
Aber wenn ihr euch jetzt trotzdem fragt,
ob vielleicht schon mal Daten von euch irgendwie irgendwo öffentlich geworden sind,
unten in der Beschreibung...
Ja, da gehen wir auf Dings hier.
Wie heißt das?
Have I been pwned oder so was?
Gibt es doch da so eine Seite für.
...Findet ihr zwei Links.
Und gerade jetzt, in Zeiten von Corona, ist das nämlich eine Gefahr,
weil viele im Homeoffice arbeiten.
Firmendaten laufen überall.
Über Heimnetze.
Und das bedeutet eine größere Gefahr für die Angriffe.
Da hat er recht, da ist richtig.
Haben die Have I been pwned oder so verlinkt?
Ja, die ist wirklich gut.
Wie sieht es aus?
Schützt ihr euch irgendwie vor Hackerangriffen?
Mein Kollege Alex, der hat sich schon mit dem Thema...
Da könnt ihr eure E-Mail-Adresse eingeben und gucken,
ob die in irgendeinem Leak drinne war.
Meine war auch schon überall drinne.
Private, so ein...
Guck mal, Apptweet-Accounts.
Ach ja, easy.
Passwords, ich glaube, ich habe kein Apptweet-Account.
Good news, no pwnage foul. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Ja, also man muss sagen, auch wenn jetzt...
Der Chat war ja mit dem Video nicht so zufrieden.
Man hat eigentlich nichts gesehen, wo wirklich gehackshort wurde.
Der Einzige, der wohl ernsthaft Ahnung hat und wusste, was er treibt,
ist der, ich habe vergessen, wie er heißt, der mit der eigenen Firma.
Und...
Der...
Die anderen, weiß ich nicht, was da alles dran ist.
Kein Schimmer.
Also am wenigsten Hexer war eindeutig der DDoS-Mensch.
Ich meine, irgendwelche Tools runterladen und dann auf...
Hier bitte jetzt einmal 20 Millionen Anfragen schicken, kann jeder.
Kreditkartendaten irgendwo im...
Über Tor kaufen kann auch jeder und die dann weiterverkaufen,
braucht man nur die nötige kriminelle Energie dazu.
Das ist jetzt...
Das hat jetzt mit Hacken auch wenig zu tun.
So.
Und ich habe mich vertan, weil ich gedacht habe, er verwendet Ubuntu,
aber es war Kali-Linux, hätte ich mal mit den Bookmarks angeguckt.
Was aber auch für Hexer deutlich...
Also gerade bei...
Das war ja eher sowas Richtung Penetration-Tests,
was der Typ da gezeigt hat.
Da ist Kali-Linux natürlich das Ding, was viele verwenden.
So, gut.
Also das neue iPhone wollen wir uns angucken.
SE.
Zeig mal.
Was haben wir denn da?
Also eins muss man ja sagen,
gute Presentations und Ankündigungen können die von Apple echt machen.
Zum Thema Kali-Linux muss ich noch einmal eine Sache erzählen von der Arbeit.
Anscheinend ist Kali-Linux mittlerweile so bekannt von den URLs und den Repos,
die die verwenden, dass...
Wir haben uns mal einen Kali-Linux installiert in einer VM auf der Arbeit
und da kam...
Viertelstunde später kam irgendwie einer vom Security-Team und hat gesehen,
oh, wir hätten hier komische Hexer-Hacker-Tools installiert über den Proxy.
Da haben wir dann eine Runde so gemacht.
Und haben einfach den Proxy verwendet, ja.
Jetzt habe ich den ganzen Anfang verpasst.
Seht ihr was?
Touch-ID.
Dass der Touch-ID hat, finde ich gut.
Ganz ehrlich, mir gefällt Touch-ID besser als Face.
Ja gut, braucht kein Mensch.
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Ah, das ist ganz praktisch.
Was ist mit der Musik los?
Okay, das ist eine typische Apple-Präsentation.
Man erfährt nichts.
Wunderbar.
Das ist so eine typische Apple-Präsentation, Alter.
Ja gut, gemacht sind die Apple-Videos immer.
So, blablabla.
Wir sind hier bei einer Seite mit Chip.
Also die Seite unserer Wahl.
Ja, Chip.
Ich hatte früher mal...
Kein Chip, aber ich hatte früher mal ein PC-Welt-Abo.
Ganz, ganz früher.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen?
Das war richtig cringe.
Chip hatte ich nie.
Ähm.
Also.
Home-Taste.
Äußerlich exakt wie das iPhone 8.
Okay, das habe ich mir gedacht.
Das heißt, es ist auch eine ganze Ecke größer.
Also.
iPhone 8.
Abmaße.
Okay.
So.
Und was hatte...
Und was hatte das...
Auf was basiert nochmal das aktuelle SE?
Auf dem 5S?
Auf was ist das aktuelle SE?
Ja.
Also.
Ja, es ist schon eine ganze Ecke größer.
Guck mal.
138.
Also sagen wir mal 14, 14 cm.
7 cm.
So das alte...
Ja, das ist so eine ganze Ecke.
So ein Daumenbreit auseinander gezogen.
Hä?
Wie Zentimeter?
Chat.
138,4 mm.
Sind ziemlich genau 14 cm.
Oder will der Chat jetzt irgendwas anderes behaupten?
Ein Meter, ja.
Gerundet.
Ja, am besten machen wir jetzt noch in Fuß oder sowas.
Ja.
Es ist ein bisschen größer.
Gibt es einen Vergleich?
8.
Komparsion.
Oh, ja.
Guck mal.
Ah, das ist doch ein schöner Vergleich.
So.
Das 7. denken wir uns mal weg.
Da wusste ich gar nicht mehr, dass das überhaupt mal existiert hat.
Hier.
Also es ist schon ein ordentlicher Unterschied zwischen einem 8er und einem SE.
Ich weiß, dass es das alte SE ist.
Das ist das neue SE von den Abmaßen und das ist das alte SE von den Abmaßen.
Ich muss sagen, die Größe ist schon eine ganze Ecke mehr.
Also kommt ungefähr hin, was ich gesagt habe.
So ein Daumenbreit in die Länge auseinander gezogen.
Was ist das?
Ach.
Ja, wie gesagt, so ein Daumenbreit auseinander gezogen.
Breite ist anscheinend mehr oder weniger oder Höhe ist anscheinend mehr oder weniger das gleiche.
Bist du eigentlich Einzelkind?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie kommst du denn da drauf jetzt?
High IQ Questions hier.
Die hätten Dings interviewen sollen hier.
Nicht Overfail.
Fuck.
Fuck, wie komme ich jetzt auf Overfail?
Live Overflow.
Overfail, Alter.
Die hätten ihn interviewen sollen.
Dann weißt du ja nichts, was Sache ist.
Wie komme ich jetzt auf Overfail?
Den hätten sie interviewen können.
Nicht so komische.
Möchte gern.
Kreditkartenbetrüger.
Ach, Fail Overflow war es genau.
Das war der Twitch-Kanal. Richtig.
Wir waren nämlich irgendwas mit Fail.
Hatte ich noch im Hinterkopf.
Ja, also, ich muss sagen, ein bisschen groß, ne?
Ich habe ja extra noch ein iPhone SE für meine Mutter bestellt.
Vor einem Jahr oder zwei.
Vor zwei Jahren, einem Jahr.
Weiß ich nicht genau, schon eine Weile her.
Extra eins bestellt, gerade weil es so klein ist.
Die hatte bis dahin noch so ein komisches Mini Siemens Club Handy.
Also sprich so was, was...
Was man 1998 hatte, ja, hatte die immer noch.
Da habe ich gesagt, komm, jetzt mach mal hin.
Kaufe dir mal ein ordentliches Handy.
Nee, das alte reicht noch.
Das brauche ich doch alles nicht.
Da habe ich ihr einfach einen Apple, einen iPhone SE bestellt.
Und seitdem ist die happy mit dem iPhone SE.
So, ähm...
Und auch nur, weil es so klein ist.
Ich glaube, das Neue ist...
Das wäre ihr tatsächlich ein bisschen groß.
So.
Jetzt gucken wir endlich ein paar Battlefield 2 Videos.
Und vielleicht ein paar Battlefield-Schneiber-Clips.
Wird auch Zeit.
Muss mal wieder sein.
Der Sound von Battlefield 4 war schon echt gut, ne?
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Der Sound von Battlefield 4...
Oder generell, der beste Sound, ich sage es euch meiner Meinung nach, war
Bad Company 2 mit Wartapes.
Bester Sound.
Äh, das ist Battlefield 3, richtig.
Oh.
Huge, huge Snipe.
Wirklich...
Ist das Setup?
Weil da so doof rumstehen die Gegner?
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass das Setup ist.
Die Gegner sind einfach nur...
Aber war richtig gut.
In today's episode we've got a selection of epic clips.
Mac Devil fragt...
Hat noch wer starke Probleme mit dem WLAN bekommen
in jüngster Zeit?
Das ist schwierig zu sagen, weil das ist
eine sehr persönliche Sache bei dir mit dem WLAN.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Aber ich habe auch ordentliche Access Points.
Oder hat dir der Vodafone Support gesagt, du sollst deine SSIDs ändern?
Hast du einen 1080p Monitor?
Ja.
Immer noch.
...clips from Big E.
You know this guy is one of the best snipers
in Battlefield.
That intro clip was absolutely insane.
And these following few clips
are long range pointstacks.
I have no idea how he manages
to hit Snipes like this.
But I guess it just comes with
thousands of hours of playtime.
He manages to get some absolutely insane clips.
Some of the best I've ever seen
in Battlefield 3.
Das sind wirklich nice Snipes.
Da kann man nichts sagen.
Huge Snipes.
Zum Glück bewegen sich die Gegner auch nicht.
Zack.
Du, du, du, du.
WTF.
Alter, wie hat er den getroffen?
Krasser Scheiß.
Das ist ein aktuelles Video, ja.
Das ist ein paar Tage alt.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Ich mein, der Heli ist auch doof geflogen.
Und er hat ein paar Schüsse gebraucht.
Aber ist trotzdem immer nice.
Wenn er da beide rausnipst.
Lovi.
Grand Bazaar ist Poggers gewesen.
3. Infantry Gameplay.
Ha, wieder reinrennen.
Die Gegner wollen aber auch von ihm weggemäht werden, oder?
Die haben keinerlei Interesse da, sich ein bisschen zu bewegen.
Die Gegner haben keinerlei Interesse da, sich ein bisschen zu bewegen.
Ich kann euch, weil ich gerade wieder WLAN-Diskussionen im Chat hätte,
Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, die Access Points,
Ich hab zwei Stück von Ubiquiti,
und zwar einmal einen UAP Pro,
und zwar einmal einen UAP Pro, den da.
Und zwar einmal einen UAP Pro, den da.
Und da gibt es jetzt quasi ne neue, etwas neuere Variante von,
Und zwar den da.
Genau. Also ich hab einmal den und einmal den.
Einmal oben einstehen im ersten Stock, einmal im Erdgeschoss,
und seitdem hab ich absolut keine Probleme mehr, was das Ganze angeht.
Die Dinger sind nicht schlecht, die Dinger sind alle relativ teuer.
man kriegt garantiert
auch gute Ergebnisse mit anderen Access Points
es ist ja kein Hexenwerk
Access Points zu bauen, du brauchst da halt was
mit einer Antenne zusammen
also das können andere Anbieter
auch und man kann sich auch
vielleicht die günstigen MikroTik Access Points
kaufen und so, aber mit denen habe ich gute
Erfahrungen gemacht, die haben glaube ich vier Antennen drinnen
und
die Bauform ist auch ganz angenehm, die kann man
schön an die Wand machen oder sogar
an die Decke machen, die sind ja übrigens dafür gedacht
an die Decke gemacht zu werden, muss man sagen
und dann hat man
weniger Probleme damit
als Switch
habe ich, ich habe auch einen
Ubiquiti 10G Switch
allerdings kein Unified Switch, sondern
ein Edge Switch
mit Web Interface und Command Line Config
als Router habe ich
einen MikroTik Router
übrigens beste Waffe
meine Lieblingswaffe in dem Game
MikroTik mit DSL-Mode
MikroTik an
Connect Box
ja, das war schöne Battlefield
gegenseitig killen
erstmal schöner Metro
erstmal schöner Metro Spam
der Gegner hat mich
richtig verletzt, der Gegner hat mich
weil er nicht gecheckt hat
gut
F2000...war das?
ne das war keine F2000
das war ne AUG
Noah's Herkennnis
Hahahaha
Hast du gesehen was das
für ein
Braindead
Afk Sniper Dude gewesen wäre
was ist mit dem los?
H pou tu deixe mir ein like
Hoooooo
16 is
3. Seine Wahlwaffe und ein paar Kills auch mit dem Rex-Sekundär.
Echt satisfeindlich zu benutzen.
Er sendet viele Infanterie-Spiele ein und er beginnt zu werden einer meiner Lieblings-Kreatoren, die man sehen kann.
Linken können Sie in der Beschreibung unten unten finden, von allen Spielern in diesem Episode.
Dieses Episode von den Battlefield-Top-Playern wird von Instant Gaming gesponsert.
Wenn Sie sich für ein paar günstige Karten und vielleicht ein paar neue Spiele auswählen wollen,
dann schauen Sie sich die Linken in der Beschreibung unten unten an.
Nächster Episode, ein Battlefield-4-Clip von Annihilator, Operation Locker,
der Type-88-LNG und ein...
Die haben eh wenig an der Balance gedreht in Battlefield 3, aber die Battlefield-3-Balance war auch okay.
Es gab halt so ein paar Ausreißer, der Rest war okay.
Oh, Baguette.
Lock-on-Waffen, ja.
Das stimmt.
Wobei du Lock-on-Waffen gebraucht hast in Battlefield.
Wie hättest du sonst die Helis killen sollen?
Hättest du mit RPGs und AT4 die Helis killen sollen?
Das ist ja kein Battlefield Bad Company 2, wo die Helis langsam und fett waren.
Die Gegner!
Was ist denn mit euch los?
Die checken wir wieder...
Guckt ihr den an?
Die checken wieder gar nichts.
Alter, brain dead gehe ich da.
Der Typ, der die Treppe hochgelaufen ist, hat es wieder gar nicht gecheckt.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass irgendwie seine Waffe absolut null verzieht von der LNG?
Das ist der CZ-3A1.
Wir sehen nicht viel Infanterie-Gameplay mit diesem Waffen,
obwohl es ziemlich satisfizierend ist, es zu nutzen.
Wir haben ein paar Kills,
um den Clip auszulösen.
Er bewegt sich um dieses Objektiv.
Der Delta unten ist eine Art Multi-Layer-Objektiv.
Es gibt dieses Untergrund-Bereich und die Strecke hier
bietet immer noch interessante Close-Quarters-Aktionen.
Du machst deinen Weg durch die Seite hier
und es werden immer noch ein paar Spieler sein.
Ich will nicht sagen Campen, aber Haltengänge hier oben.
Da ist er. Ein paar sind schon runtergegangen.
Ein exzellentes Clip.
Wenn hier einer campt, dann der Gegner, der die ganze Zeit auf der Erde liegt, in eine Richtung guckt.
Der Gegner, der die ganze Zeit auf der Erde liegt, in eine Richtung guckt.
Der zweite Clip, den er ins Speicherkle opportun surprises,
zeigt蹜 von diesen tollen Close-Quarters,
gegen eine Menge von Täter, die ihn abbacken.
Dies hat eine gute Kikuszeit.
Boah, cool!
Der Gegner ist natürlich wiederLLPP-ig,
Aber der hat gutas gut gemacht.
Das letzte Video kam von den Dark Fierce und war auch imhu self.
Letzte Phase war doch wieder falsch verlinkt.
Das letzte Video war doch auch zur Halbzeit locker.
I'm kind of back watching them again.
They're really satisfying to watch.
If you like your infantry gameplay, this one is a great clip using the Magnum.
Gets a quick revive there, which is quite lucky.
I don't always include revives in top plays, but for this one I kind of had to,
because the Magnum and the Scar Age Combo is so satisfying.
Hä?
Warum sollte man keine Revives inkluden, wenn es ein nicer Streak ist?
Der Sound ist auch aus irgendeiner Kartoffel aufgenommen.
Sag mal Leute, das ist Bildschirm abgefilmt, oder?
Ist das Bildschirm abgefilmt?
Auch der Sound, der hört sich auch so platt an.
Und auch die Helligkeitsverteilung und so.
Ob das Bildschirm abgefilmt ist?
Ne.
Bam!
Foreheader.
Ja, das stimmt. Das sieht eigentlich zu gut aus für Bildschirm abgefilmt.
Zavod.
Kekobrit.
Das sieht dunkel aus.
Man sieht ja kaum die Gegner.
Hätten die nicht rote Pfeile über dem Kopf, hättest du gar nichts erkennen.
Ein schöner kleines Klepp von JSparkling.
Für irgendeine Weise spielt er auf einer gewöhnlichen Resolution.
Boah!
Was ist das?
Six Head. Auflösung.
Das sieht ein bisschen seltsam aus.
Aber viele Töne mit diesem MG4.
Und ein bisschen über die Gegner-Team hier.
Keiner von ihnen hat sich wirklich auf den Fakt, dass er hinter ihnen ist.
Er bekommt 1500 Punkte in diesen Stack, bevor er letztendlich abgenommen wird.
Hoffentlich hat euch dieses Episode des Battlefield Top Plays gefallen.
Wenn es euch gefallen hat, lasst einen Daumen nach unten.
Wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat, lasst einen Daumen nach unten.
Erinnert euch, ihr könnt die Spieler-Kanäle in der Beschreibung unten finden.
Und auch eure Clips an battlefieldtopplays.gmail.com.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ah, den gucke ich immer gern.
Was haben wir sonst noch für Videos zur Auswahl?
Fiverr, PC-Zusammenstellung, Expensive Motherboards.
Der Auer ist auch wieder am Start.
Image PS4 Games?
Double your Internet Speed, Wispier.
Oh nee, das ist irgendein Cheap Aid Video.
Flutter in 100 Seconds.
100 Seconds.
Das gucken wir uns auch an.
Der Wish.com PC ist
eingekommen. Aha.
Was ist das?
Linux?
Warum habe ich denn das aufgemacht?
Vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, vielleicht taugt es ja was.
Und der Twitch-Emote-Song.
Aber den hatten wir schon.
All these
Emotes
Moved on
Remember
Twitch Chat
Those days that are gone
Twitch-Emotes
Long ago
Make you feel
You're not alone
Kappa
PogChamp
People for it
Bible Thumb
Twitch-Emotes
So, genug.
Hör mal auf.
Das ist ja Körperverletzter.
Ja, Flutter in 100 Seconds.
Äh, 100 Seconds.
Beautiful.
Excellent.
UI-Framework for building apps on
iOS, Android, the Web and Desktop.
At its core, Flutter combines a
high-performance graphics engine with the
Dart-Programming language.
In development, Dart provides...
Ich wollte mir auch schon seit längerer Zeit mal Flutter angucken.
Aber leider, aber leider ist halt
auf dem Desktop noch nicht so richtig brauchbar.
...full-type safety and stateful hot reload
to help you build reliable apps quickly.
In production, Dart compiles to native machine code,
which means your graphics will render beautifully on...
Sollte ich mal irgendwann eine richtig echte App
programmieren wollen und es eine PWA nicht tun,
dann werde ich es wahrscheinlich mit Flutter machen.
...on any platform.
Wozu?
Install Flutter, then run Flutter Create
to create a new project.
Now open the main Dart file.
This is where you build your app.
The UI is laid out as a tree of widgets.
And the framework provides hundreds of pre-built widgets
to handle things like animation, scrolling,
responsive layout and more.
You can build your own widget by extending the stateless widget class.
You then define your UI by overwriting its build method.
Now it's...
Extents und dieser Attribut, irgendwie erinnert mich das an Java.
Bin ich da der Einzige?
It's important to understand that everything in Flutter is a widget.
This method returns a widget and its children return widgets
and their children return widgets,
giving us an expressive declarative UI structure,
which you can easily traverse using Flutter's awesome tooling.
Whenever the input data to this widget changes,
Flutter will rebuild the UI,
by calling your build method.
Stateless widgets are immutable and don't have any internal data.
When you have an interactive...
Das verstehe ich auch nicht, warum sie das in der eigenen Sprache
für Flutter gebraucht haben.
Das leuchtet mir auch nicht ein.
Chris Stonehenge, sieben Monate, dankeschön.
Huge sub.
Samus Klymer!
Widgets where the internal data might change based on user input,
you can extend a stateful widget.
Properties defined on this class...
Oh, ich hab noch den Nacho Libre vergessen.
Acht Monate.
Dankeschön für den sub.
... can be reactive.
For example, we might have a calendar widget.
We might have a counter that starts at zero.
Then in our build method, we have one of Flutter's built-in buttons that calls a function whenever
it's pressed.
It increments the counter by calling setState, which tells the framework that the widget's
data has changed, causing the UI to re-render with the latest data.
You can now play with this app on a real device using the flutter run command.
That's cool and all, but let's make some changes.
We'll go back to our source code and center the button on the middle of the screen.
Instead of writing code, just click on the button and hit Ctrl-Shift-R, then wrap your
button with a center widget.
What?
Next, change the color of the button.
This is how Flutter previews that color directly in your IDE.
Now to hot-reload the app, simply type R in the command line and press Ctrl-Shift-R.
It only took a few milliseconds to build a new version of our app.
And notice how the state of the counter was unchanged.
That's what I like to call an awesome developer experience.
This has been Flutter in 100 seconds.
If you want to learn more, check out my newly updated Flutter Firebase video.
Thanks for watching and I will see you in the next one.
Ciao!
Also sprich, wenn ich vorher maximal 5 MB im Download kriege, kriege ich danach auch 5 MB im Download, weil das eine Verbindung ist.
Und das ist nun wirklich nichts besonderes, sowas zu basteln.
Was hat er da am Start?
Bridged VDSL.
Vielleicht wird es doch ein bisschen advancer und er hat eine Gegenstelle im Internet.
Woran er das ganze Layer 2 koppelt irgendwie.
Das könnte natürlich schon interessant sein.
MacServer.
MonkaS.
Eigentlich interessieren mich nur die Tests am Ende, wenn er was zeigt.
Okay.
Ich dachte, er zeigt einen Download zwischendurch.
Vorher, nachher.
Dann hoffen wir mal, dass er es tatsächlich richtig gemacht hat.
Magst du das Hälsen von Plurals sein?
War das diese Kurs...
Diese Kursseite, sowas wie...
Ist das nicht sowas wie Udemy gewesen?
Weiß gar nicht genau, was es ist.
Ja, aber halt etwas...
Ich habe noch nie so einen Kurs gemacht.
Okay, was haben die so?
Courses.
C-Sharp-Kurs.
Okay.
Was kann man da lernen?
C-Sharp-Tipps und Tricks.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Jason Roberts and welcome to my course C-Sharp Tips and Traps.
I'm a freelance developer and...
Ah, Tipps and Traps.
Nicht Tipps, Tipps and Tricks.
Tipps and Traps.
Whether you're still learning C-Sharp or you already have some experience,
it's often hard to know what you don't know.
This course is designed to short-circuit your C-Sharp learning.
It provides a whole host of useful information about the sometimes underused
or unknown features of both C-Sharp and .NET.
Yes.
Some of the major topics that we'll cover include...
Also, scheint mir gut gemacht zu sein.
Kann man zum Inhalt jetzt nichts sagen.
...and formatting tips, tips for working with files, paths and URIs...
Gut, das ist wirklich Easy Mode.
Ja, da muss man nichts großartig lernen.
...on organizing and structuring classes and code...
Auch nichts.
...code compilation tips and tips on casting and converting.
By the end of this course, you will have filled in the gaps in your C-Sharp knowledge
and learned a whole host of useful C-Sharp tips...
C-Sharp tips and...
Also, von der Production her sieht das ganz okay aus.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kann dazu nichts sagen.
Ich habe noch nie solche Kurse gemacht.
Da Benzel schreibt, danke by the way für deinen Tipp von MikroTik.
Hab mir nun einen MapLight bestellt.
Was ist denn das?
Ist das ein Access Point?
Ach, das sind die Dinger.
Ja, da habe ich auch zwei Stück von.
Das sind ganz kleine Mini-Access Points.
Da habe ich auch zwei Stück von.
Einer liegt hier hinter mir.
Und einen habe ich in meiner Klingel eingebaut vorne.
Aber der wird auch nicht verwendet.
Der ist einfach nur da.
Weil ich ihn mal verwenden wollte.
Will den für Hotels verwenden?
Ja, dafür ist das gut.
Dafür ist das sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Der ist ein bisschen schwachbrüstig, was RAM und CPU angeht.
Aber natürlich für einen Rechner vollkommen ausreichend.
Du hast ein komplettes Router-OS drauf.
Also, das Ding ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Vor allem für den Preis.
Der Kram kostet nichts.
Also, im Verhältnis zu anderen.
Das ist wirklich saugünstig.
Guck mal, 4,25 Euro.
Du kriegst einen kompletten Linux-Router mit WLAN drinnen für 25 Euro.
Da kannst du dich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Du kannst natürlich hier performance-mäßig keine Wunde erwarten.
Das ist auch kein 5 GHz WLAN.
Das ist nur 2,4 GHz WLAN.
Aber vollkommen ausreichend.
Und feature-mäßig top.
Da gibt es nichts daran auszusetzen.
So, der Wish-PC.
Wish.com.
PC ist angekommen.
Zeig mal her.
Ich hatte jetzt schon ein paar Videos von ihm.
Und ich habe mich bei einigen Videos echt debated gefühlt.
Da steht was im Titel.
Und da kommt was, was nicht so wirklich das ist, was ich sehen wollte.
Spread the Beast.
Zehn Monate.
Monka Old.
Aber richtig, richtig old.
Aber.
Ein richtig echter.
Nice.
Aber nur Unboxing.
Okay, das ist natürlich doof.
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt ein bisschen was, was der, was das Ding kann.
Ja, nur, nur Unboxing ist in der Tat langweilig.
Nur Unboxing ist in der Tat langweilig.
Ja.
Na ja, da gucken wir das nicht.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch Schönes?
Wir haben schon lange kein Fortunate-Video mehr geguckt.
Was macht der denn aktuell so?
Still Alive, Black Ops 1.
Hm.
Eher weniger.
Ich habe es ja auch letztens mal wieder ausprobiert.
Yo, what is going on?
What is going on, guys?
Das können wir uns nachher nochmal angucken.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
AMD Desktop, 16 Kerne in einem Notebook.
Ah ja, und dazu noch etwas Flüssigstoff.
Nein, das ist der Bauer, da muss Flüssigstoff am Start sein.
Das geht ja nicht anders.
Komm Dick, mal gucken, was er, was er so zu bieten hat.
Ergibt es Sinn?
Was?
Moment, die Frage muss ich erst mal parsen im Kopf,
da ich sie kapiere.
Ergibt es Sinn, meine 2 mal 8 Gigabyte DDR4,
mit 1 mal 8 Gigabyte RAM zu erweitern?
Ja, warum nicht, wenn du zu wenig RAM hast?
Ja, diese Dual-Channel-Geschichte,
da würde ich mal nicht zu viel Bedeutung beimessen.
Also, wenn du jetzt RAM-Probleme hast,
dann ist es auf jeden Fall sinnvoll zu erweitern.
Ich habe letztens auch erweitert von 16G auf 32G,
aber ich habe halt 2 mal 8 noch dabei gestöpselt.
Also, was hat der Bauer uns zu sagen?
Willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Es geht mal wieder um ein Notebook.
Tatsächlich auch schon wieder mit AMD.
Wir haben uns ja vor einigen Wochen den AMD 4000 Mobile angeschaut.
Absolut brillante CPU, 4900HS.
Den hatten wir in einem Asus ROG Notebook uns angeschaut.
Und heute haben wir hier einen XMG Schenker Apex 15 Laptop.
Die Dinger haben immer einen Namen, Alter.
Hau dir schon den Namen an, ey.
Manche von euch kennen das Teil vielleicht schon.
Wenn ich mir das so von außen ansehe, Laptop,
dann erinnert mich das ein bisschen an mein Nissan GT-R, muss ich sagen.
Von außen nicht mehr der neueste Start.
Ja, ja, klar macht das Unterschied, ob Dual Channel oder nicht.
Aber wenn man jetzt zu wenig RAM hat,
dann ist die Alternative mehr RAM einbauen definitiv besser
und auf Dual Channel verzichten definitiv besser als zu wenig RAM haben.
Wenn man innen reinsitzt in mein Nintendo,
dann ist das definitiv besser als zu wenig RAM.
Also, wenn man innen reinsitzt in mein Nintendo,
Wenn man innen reinsitzt in mein Nintendo,
dann ist das definitiv besser als zu wenig RAM.
Was hat die Logistik Sparte der Bahn mit Laptops zu tun?
Die machen schon ewig Laptops.
XMG.
Die gibt es schon ganz lange.
MochaDB.
Kann man nicht ein 2x4 Kit kaufen und ein 8x8 44 stecken?
Ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert.
Die müssen alles von vor zehn Jahren,
aber die Leistung müsste,
Und das ist bei dem XMG Apex 15 genauso.
Wirklich total krank, denn hier drin sind AMD...
Und wie lange hält der Akku? 20 Minuten?
Top-CPUs verbaut.
XMG hat mir auch diverse CPUs mitgeschickt.
Wir haben noch einen 3600, einen 3700X und dann haben wir hier einen 3950X AMD 16-Kan-Prozessor.
Und der soll da reinpassen.
Und das ist wirklich unfassbar krass.
Einen normalen Laptop mit Desktop-Hardware zu verwenden, Clivo bzw. XMG ist ja dafür schon länger bekannt.
Und das Ganze jetzt mit einem AMD 16-Kan-Prozessor.
Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was die Leistung betrifft.
Und ich würde sagen, wir schauen uns das Ding als erstes Mal von innen an, wie der Aufbau von dem Teil gemacht wurde.
Dieses Video wird unterstützt von der neuen Wireless-FPS-Gaming-Maus Dark Core.
Guck mal, jetzt sind wir schon so weit, dass Mäuse Videos präsentieren können.
...Pro SE von Corsair.
Die kabellose Premium-Maus eignet sich hingegen...
...durch die Corsair Slipstream-Wireless-Technologie und damit verbundener Latenz von unter einer Millisekunde, auch ohne Kabel.
Hervorragend für FPS- und MOBA-Games.
Neben der Slipstream-Funkverbindung lässt sich die Maus aber auch mit herkömmlichem Bluetooth und USB-C verbinden.
Die SE-Variante bietet zusätzlich auch die Möglichkeit, die Dark Core RGB Pro zum Beispiel über das Corsair MM1000-Mauspad induktiv zu laden.
Ah, yes.
Das ist cool.
Die Maus induktiv laden, warum nicht?
Das finde ich ist eine gute Sache.
...bei bis zu 50 Stunden.
Der Pixar PRW3392-Sensor mit 18.000 dpi ist besonders energieeffizient und bietet maximale Präzision.
Die Polling-Rate von 2000 Hz, zwei austauschbare Seitenteile und eine 9-Zonen-RGB-Beleuchtung runden den Naga dabei ab.
Mehr findet ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Ihr fragt euch jetzt vielleicht, warum habe ich das gesagt, dass es meinem Nissan GT-R ähnelt.
Ja, die Verarbeitungsqualität, also wenn man das von außen so mal anschaut, dann erinnert mich das so ein bisschen mehr an ein Notebook von vor 5, 6, 7 Jahren.
Also, die Verarbeitungsqualität ist gut, versteht mich nicht falsch, aber gerade, wenn ich mir so die Rückseite anschaue, dann fühlt sich das jetzt nicht so...
Warum immer so hohe dpi-Zahlen, weil es sich gut anhört, weil es sich gut anhört.
Niemand, den ich kenne, spielt mit seiner Maus auf 18.000 dpi oder sowas.
Du kannst ja, wie willst du das, wenn du auf 18.000 dpi spielst, mit den normalen Settings, dann ist bei dieser Bewegung, ist das Ding einmal über den Bildschirm drüber.
Es ist aber nicht schlecht, wenn der Sensor das kann.
Ich meine, das ist ja...
Ja.
Ich meine, wenn der Sensor das kann und du stellst es dann selber runter, ist immer noch besser als umgedreht.
Also, die meisten spielen, genau, die meisten spielen 400 oder 800, manche spielen 1200 und machen die Sens dann ordentlich runter, aber die meisten, die ich kenne, spielen 400 oder 800.
Ich spiele 800.
Mega krass hochwertig an, es passt nicht so ganz zu der Leistung, die in diesem Teil stecken wird.
Ich muss dazu aber auch sagen, dass wir hier einen der absolut ersten Prototypen haben und ich dementsprechend auch
nicht hundertprozentig sagen kann, ob alles daran genauso im finalen Produkt sein wird.
Also, was Leistung betrifft, auf jeden Fall.
Vom Design her kann ich das euch nicht hundertprozentig verraten.
Im Lieferumfang ist übrigens eine 62 Watt-Stunden-Batterie dabei, die lässt sich sehr, sehr einfach entfernen.
Alles bei diesem Teil ist auf Upgradebarkeit ausgelegt, was ich extrem cool finde und ich würde sagen, ich zeige euch einfach mal, wie man das Teil aufmacht und wie es innen aussieht.
Ihr müsst hier die einzelnen paar Schrauben lösen und dann könnt ihr...
Wieso kauft man sich so einen Laptop, den man eh nicht mitnehmen wird?
Das frage ich mich auch.
Die einzige Sache, die ich mir erklären kann, ist, wenn man häufig wechselnde, aber dann längere Zeit feste Plätze hat, wo man spielen will.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man öfters in irgendwelchen Hotels ist und dort abends krasse Zock-Action machen will.
Dann vielleicht.
Ähm...
Oder wenn man ein übelster Pro-Gamer ist und irgendwie gar unterwegs im Team-Bus spielen will.
Keine Ahnung.
So einen genauen Anwendungszweck habe ich dafür auch nicht.
Das Fach einfach nach oben wegsliden und aufmachen.
Das ist so viel einfacher als bei den meisten Notebooks, die ich kenne.
Dann sehen wir hier direkt, wir haben zwei M2-Slots.
Einer davon ist bereits belegt mit einer neuen...
So heiß, wie die SSDs heutzutage schon werden.
Ist das wahrscheinlich.
Wenn du dir das aufs Bein stellst, hast du einfach Brandflecken.
Pro 512 GB SSD.
Das kann man sicherlich auch selbst konfigurieren bei XMG im Shop.
Dann haben wir hier aktuell zwei RAM-Module verbaut mit 2666 C18.
Das ist natürlich nicht ganz so schnell.
XMG hat mir auch diese Crucial Sticks hier mitgeschickt.
Die haben dann 3200 MHz, allerdings CL22.
Was aus meiner Sicht relativ langsam ist.
Und deswegen habe ich mir kurzerhand noch ein 3200 MHz CL16 32 GB Kit bestellt.
Und damit sollte die Geschwindigkeit dann passen.
Das bauen wir gleich mal ein.
Was habe ich nochmal für RAM?
Wartet mal, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was ich für ein RAM habe.
Was habe ich für RAM?
Moment.
Hier.
Da.
Oh, ich habe besseren RAM.
Wahnsinn.
3200.
CL14 habe ich.
Huge.
Mit RGB.
Dadurch wird es nochmal doppelt so schnell.
Ich habe 4x8 mittlerweile drin.
4x8.
Natürlich keine kurze S0-Dings-Bauweise, sondern normale Länge.
Das ist echt der Witz.
Muss ich jetzt gerade noch drauf eingehen.
Guckt mal, wann ich mir diesen Rechner gekauft habe.
Oktober 2017.
Also, das Ding ist in einem halben Jahr 3 Jahre alt.
Und es ist immer noch absolut top high.
Vielleicht nicht high end mehr, sondern high.
Auf jeden Fall noch ganz oben mit dabei.
8700K, 1080Ti.
Es ist krass, wie langlebig Rechner-Hardware mittlerweile ist.
Es hat sich wenig geändert.
Und die 1080Ti ist halt krass schnell gewesen.
Ja.
Die habe ich jetzt auch schon.
Die habe ich ja nur schon im alten Rechner gehabt.
Die habe ich keine 4 Jahre oder so jetzt.
Wann habe ich die 1080Ti?
Da habe ich doch auch ein Video zu gemacht.
Hier.
Seit Juli 2017.
Also, die habe ich jetzt 3 Jahre.
So kurz nur.
Und die war damals schon ein bisschen älter, ja.
Release.
1080Ti.
Die gab es schon eine Weile.
Guck mal, 2017.
Ich habe die erst ein Jahr nach Release geholt.
Guck mal, 3 Jahre gibt es die jetzt.
Und es ist immer noch so.
Und es ist immer noch eine der schnellsten Grafikkarten überhaupt.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Also, das hat so um die 2000, 2005.
Da war das, nach 2 Jahren war der Rechner für den Arsch.
Die meisten meiner Benchmarks habe ich immer auf so einer Corsair MP600 mit einem Terabyte.
Und die bauen wir dann auch gleich noch ein, wenn wir sowieso noch einen M2-Slot frei haben.
Hauptsache mehr SSDs.
SSDs, man kann nie genug SSDs haben, sehe ich genauso.
SSDs beste.
Es gibt nur noch mehr SSDs.
Wenn ich jetzt noch eine normale 2,5 Zoll SATA-SSD, dann könnte ich die hier zum Beispiel auch noch reinpacken als zusätzlichen Datenspeicher.
Für den Laptop kann man da aber ziemlich viel reinmachen.
Und was wiegt das dann am Ende?
20 Kilo.
Entspannende Musik.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Damit ist die Kühlkonstruktion jetzt erstmal entfernt und wir sehen einen AMD Ryzen Desktop-Prozessor.
Hier links haben wir übrigens den Grafikprozessor.
Je nachdem, was für ein Modell ihr habt, ist das eine RTX 2060.
Oder eine RTX 2070.
Jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht, wie ist es überhaupt möglich, dass wir einen 3950X mit 16 Kernen in so einem Laptop haben.
Und wie bekommt man das gekühlt?
Also wir haben zwar eine sehr gute Kühlkonstruktion, also ordentlich Heatpipes dran.
Sechs an der Zahl, wenn ich das auf den ersten Blick so gut erkenne.
Massiv viel Kupfer.
Massive.
Aber die Oberfläche, auch wenn es extrem viele Finnen sind, können natürlich keinen Desktop-Kühler ersetzen.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Das Ganze funktioniert nur, weil der 3950X hier im Eco-Mode läuft und auf 65 Watt maximal gedeckelt ist.
Dadurch boostet die CPU natürlich nicht so hoch.
Der Takt ist allgemein niedriger, aber wir haben immer noch 16 Kerne.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Und heutige CPUs sind meistens so energieeffizient, dass wenn man denen ein bisschen die Leistung drosselt,
man nicht im gleichen Verhältnis Leistung bzw. Performance verliert.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir von 100...
Ist ja beim Übertakten ähnlich.
Haben wir da auch bei der Leistung gesehen.
Die Stromaufnahme steigt extrem, aber die Leistung nicht im gleichen Maße.
5 Watt TDP auf 65 Watt TDP gehen, dann klingt es ja nach, okay, wir verlieren fast die Hälfte an der Leistung.
So ist es aber nicht.
Wir reduzieren zwar die Leistungsaufnahme erheblich, aber die Leistung, ich würde schätzen, wir verlieren vielleicht um die 20%.
Haben aber immer noch 16 Kerne und das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
Die Kenner von euch werden das vielleicht schon an der Farbe sehen.
XMG verwendet bei den Notebooks übrigens Thermal Grizzly Kryonaut.
Das heißt, wir haben hier eine sehr hochwertige Wärmeleitpaste verbaut.
Dementsprechend lohnt sich das auch nicht wirklich, das Teil zu öffnen, um die beste Wärmeleitpaste zu ersetzen.
Das würde sich höchstens mit Flüssigmetall lohnen.
Da haben wir aber das Problem, dass das hier alles nacktes Kupfer ist und nicht vernickelt.
Da habe ich aber was Spezielles für ein weiteres Video geplant.
Lasst euch da einfach mal überraschen.
Erstmal schön eingeschmiert, jawoll.
Die Kappa Pride Wärmeleitpaste.
Wisst ihr, was ich da schon mal direkt loben muss und sehr, sehr geil finde?
Ich kann einfach Netzwerke anschließen.
Ich muss kein WLAN verwenden.
Windows-Updates, 5 Minuten, erledigt.
Ich bin jetzt gerade mittendrin am Testen.
Habe jetzt gerade schon 2-3 Stunden damit verbracht, den RAM richtig einzustellen bzw. zu versuchen, den RAM richtig einzustellen,
weil das Ganze funktioniert leider nicht so ganz.
Ich habe zwar eine BIOS-Saison bekommen, wo zusätzliche Einstellungen freigeschalten wurden.
Also...
Wo man erst noch RAM einstellen muss.
Ich habe dann Zugriff auf das AMD-CBS-Menü und so weiter.
Kann dann in die RAM-Einstellungen gehen.
Kann da rein theoretisch den RAM-Takt einstellen und auch die Latenzen.
Wird aber nicht übernommen.
Also ich habe ja 3200 C16.
Habe alles ausprobiert.
3000 C18, was auch immer.
Bootet alles nicht.
Ich habe jetzt aktuell 2666 C18.
Das ist das einzige, was ich gerade verwenden kann.
Das ist aber erstmal nicht so wild.
Das kann man ja BIOS-technisch hoffentlich noch ein bisschen nachbessern,
weil das mit diesem AMD-Untermenü auch nicht ganz so geschickt gelöst ist.
Das zeige ich euch gleich.
Aber dann mal was ganz anderes nebenbei.
Wer hat eigentlich diesen dämlichen AMD Ryzen Master programmiert?
Hört ihr, wie das rauscht im Hintergrund?
Die Software regt mich jedes Mal so unfassbar auf.
Die Tatsache, dass man nicht die Sprache ändern kann, ist ja sowas von dämlich.
Ich muss die Software installieren und muss dann im Installationspfad
Deutsch, Französisch und Chinesisch löschen,
dass ich Englisch verwenden kann.
Wer denkt sich sowas aus?
Weil die deutsche Übersetzung ist sowas von schlecht.
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn teilweise, die deutsche Übersetzung.
Deswegen, ach ja, AMD Ryzen Master.
Eigentlich eine coole Software.
Ich finde es cool, dass AMD das macht.
Aber diese Übersetzung, absolut grausam.
So sieht das im BIOS aus, was ich da habe.
Also man kann wirklich sehr, sehr viel einstellen.
Es gibt viele Einstellungsmöglichkeiten,
die aber leider nicht so wirklich funktionieren.
Also wenn ich jetzt ins AMD CBS gehe
und gehe dann zum Beispiel auf die UMC Common Options,
also da kann ich dann DDR4-Einstellungen machen,
kann dann hier Timing Configurator, Accept, bla bla bla.
Und wenn ich dann hier sowas zum Beispiel einstelle,
das übernimmt er nicht.
Also da seht ihr, da kann ich den RAM-Takt einstellen.
Das setzen wir jetzt erstmal wieder runter auf Auto.
Hier ist es auch übrigens so, dass man die RAM-Einstellungen in Hex-Werten machen muss,
was jetzt nicht unbedingt ein Problem für mich ist.
Von Hex in Dezimal ist umzurechnen.
Aber warum?
Aber für einen normalen End-User ist es sehr, sehr umständlich, sage ich mal.
Also würde ich mir auf jeden Fall besser wünschen.
Einfacher.
Kommen wir jetzt mal zu unserem ersten Test.
Eins bis neun in Hex ist auch einfach.
Und zwar machen wir den Cinebench R20
und schauen uns dabei sowohl Taktraten als auch Score,
als auch ein bisschen die Temperatur an.
Das können wir im Ryzen Master relativ gut anschauen.
Da sehen wir dann eben auch gut TDC und EDC.
Das sieht man schon sehr, sehr gut.
Die CPU ist direkt am vorgegebenen Limit.
Das heißt, wir haben hier direkt das Limit von 90 Ampere EDC, 60 Ampere TDC.
Wurde direkt erreicht.
Was ist denn der Unterschied, Chat?
Profi-Chat.
Was ist denn der Unterschied?
Was ist EDC und TDC?
Termal?
Keine Ahnung.
EDC?
Der Name.
Big-Brain-Antwort.
Ist das Eco?
Eco-Mode?
Und Leistungs-, also irgendwie?
Nee.
Okay, ich muss googlen.
Overdrive.
Aha.
Was auch immer.
Wir glauben, der Bauer weiß, was er macht.
Und CPU hat jetzt hier circa 55 Watt Leistungsaufnahme
und bleibt dabei wirklich angenehm kühl.
Also wir sind nicht am Temperaturlimit von der Kühlung.
Das heißt, die Kühlung ist wirklich sehr, sehr gut.
Sondern einfach nur am Stromlimit.
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr interessant zu sehen.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir es schaffen, TDC, EDC und PPT zu erhöhen,
dann sollten wir da noch Leistung rausholen können,
weil wir haben noch circa, würde ich sagen, 15 bis 20 Grad Temperaturspielraum.
Score mit 7000 Punkten ist natürlich schon sehr, sehr krass.
Und wir sehen, das liegt hier circa auf dem Niveau von dem 3900X mit Desktop-Kühlung.
Wenn wir uns den Single-Core-Score anschauen mit 444,000,
dann ist das ziemlich auf dem Niveau vom 4900HS, aber eben Multi-Score.
Sag mal, im Vergleich, steht da meiner irgendwo drin in meiner CPU?
Ja, meine CPU müsste ein bisschen oben drüber kommen hier wahrscheinlich.
Was wird denn mein 8700K haben?
Ich habe den ja ein bisschen übertaktet.
Wahrscheinlich 500 Single-Core oder sowas.
Score ist wirklich krass viel höher.
Ich wollte jetzt im Ryzen Master eigentlich EDC und TDC,
und so weiter, verstellen.
Wenn ich auf Manual gehe, habe ich die Option, aber leider gar nicht.
Aber bei Precision Boost Overdrive, also bei PBO,
da kann ich das tatsächlich irgendwie einstellen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Exzellente Oberfläche.
Das übernehmen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Also TDC war vorher bei 60, EDC bei 90, ist jetzt 114 und 168.
PPT war vorher 88, ist jetzt 152.
Ja stimmt, was macht eigentlich AMD mit Powerpoint-Präsentationen? Gute Frage.
Ich bin gespannt, ob das so funktioniert.
Ja, das hat ja gut funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollten wir kleinere Schritte probieren.
Probieren wir mal TDC 75, EDC 105.
Man sieht auf jeden Fall, dass die Temperatur schon ein bisschen höher wird als vorhin.
Also wir sind jetzt eher so Richtung 80 Grad Celsius,
wo wir vorhin bei maximal 75 Grad Celsius waren.
8000 Punkte.
Vielleicht schafft es AMD ja mit Sockel-AMD fünfmal,
dass diese Dämm-CPU nicht immer am Kühler kleben bleibt.
Das wäre natürlich was.
Das gleiche, was man beim Desktop immer hat,
ist ja auch anscheinend bei Notebooks ein bisschen ein Problem.
Weil hier kann man den Kühler nicht so wirklich nach links und rechts drehen,
bevor man den löst, so wie man das im Desktop immer machen soll.
Das ist hier schwierig.
CPU ist nicht beschädigt, aber ich tausche jetzt den 3950X für ein paar Tests erstmal gegen den 3700X aus.
Kommen wir jetzt zwischendurch mal kurz zu ein paar Benchmarks.
Wir starten mit dem Cinebench R20.
Einfach nur, dass ihr einordnen könnt, wie sich der 3950X in diesem Laptop verhält
versus einem zum Beispiel 3900X auf dem Desktop.
Er hat den doch gerade ausgebaut.
Oder 3950X im Desktop.
Also der 3950X im Apex 15 ist von der Multicore-Leistung ungefähr auf dem gleichen Niveau
wie ein 3900X 12-Kerner in einem Desktop-PC.
Wenn man dann die TDC- und EDC-Limits soweit anhebt, wie wir es gerade gemacht haben,
dann liegen wir schon deutlich vor einem 3900X.
Und das ist verglichen damit, dass es natürlich in dem Laptop steckt, äußerst respektabel.
Bei Adobe Premiere 2020 4K Video-Rendering,
da liegen wir sowohl ohne als auch mit Power-Limit-Aufhebung deutlich vor einem 3900X im Desktop
und circa eine Minute hinter einem 3950X in einem Desktop.
Also sehr, sehr respektabel.
Alles klar.
Die Ergebnisse auch hier mit circa 11 Minuten.
Dann habe ich mich auch gefragt, wie ist diese ganze Geschichte beim Gaming.
Wenn wir jetzt den 3950X betrachten...
Ich glaube eben, das Ding ist zackig für einen Notebook.
Was mich ja mal interessieren würde, ob das wirklich am Akku länger als, keine Ahnung, 40 Minuten läuft.
40 Prozent von der maximalen Leistung.
Von der maximalen Leistungsaufnahme deckeln.
Dann habe ich gedacht, vielleicht können wir im Gaming nicht mehr so hoch boosten
und wir verlieren Leistung.
Dass im Endeffekt zum Beispiel ein 3700X mit der Hälfte an Kernen schneller wäre.
Wäre auf jeden Fall eine realistische Theorie.
Deswegen habe ich den 3700X eingebaut
und habe das Ganze mit Shadow of the Tomb Raider in einer Benchmark-Szene nachgestellt.
Wir schauen uns erstmal kurz den Frequenzverlauf vom 3950X an.
Da sehen wir, die meisten Kerne bewegen sich zwischen 4100 und 4100.
3100 und 3600 Megahertz.
Und wenn wir das Ganze beim 3700X anschauen, dann sieht es nicht viel anders aus tatsächlich.
Also es gibt so gar keinen großen Unterschied alleine bei der reinen Frequenz.
Und wenn wir uns das Ganze jetzt nochmal als Gaming-Benchmark anschauen,
dann haben wir das Ganze auch nochmal in Nummern bestätigt.
Wir haben in beiden Benchmark-Sequenzen im Prinzip die gleichen Ergebnisse.
Wir haben average bei 3700X 71 FPS,
Minimum 52 FPS.
Und beim 3950X haben wir 69 FPS durchschnittlich und 53 im Minimum.
Also da kann man eigentlich sagen, das ist schon Messtoleranz.
Ein FPS hin oder her, das macht keinen großen Unterschied.
Da merkt man eigentlich nichts.
Was für mich tatsächlich überraschend war,
also der 3950X, der hier drin ist,
der eignet sich auch wunderbar zum Gaming bei diesem Laptop.
Ja, mich würde auch mal interessieren, was das Notebook kostet.
Das bedeutet natürlich auch, wenn ihr mit diesem Teil hier nur zocken wollt,
dann macht das keinen wirklichen Unterschied, ob ihr einen 3950X oder einen 3700X habt.
Wenn ihr wirklich nur zocken wollt,
könnt ihr auch die 8-Kern-CPU nehmen.
Macht keinen Unterschied, ob ihr da 16-Kerne oder 8-Kerne drin habt,
weil die meisten Spiele ebenso viele Kanne nicht benutzen.
Dementsprechend gleiches Ergebnis mit dem 3700X.
An dieser Stelle noch eine kleine Anmerkung zu den M2-Slots,
die in diesem Gerät verbaut sind.
Wir haben ja zwei Stück insgesamt.
Eine davon ist aber Generation 2 eingebunden und eins Generation 3.
Das sieht man hier ganz gut.
Also meine C-Festplatte hier,
das ist meine Corsair MP600.
Und wenn wir hier jetzt mal die M2-Splatte,
jetzt den Test machen,
dann sehen wir, dass das definitiv keine Generation 4 ist,
sonst wären wir da ja irgendwo bei 4500 oder 5000 MB pro Sekunde,
sondern wir sind eher bei 1500.
Und das deutet eben darauf hin,
dass das nur PCI-Express 2.0 ist.
Es ist ja nicht so, als wäre das jetzt irgendwie der große Flaschenhals.
Und nicht mal 3.0.
Warum das der Fall ist, kann ich euch nicht erklären.
Wenn wir dann aber gegentesten mit der D-Festplatte,
das ist die Samsung 79 SSD
und die ist dann in dem Generation 3.0.
Da sieht man auch gleich ganz eindeutig an den Ergebnissen.
Da haben wir dann 3500 MB pro Sekunde lesend
und auch ungefähr das gleiche im Schreiben.
Also da sieht man dann ganz deutlich,
dass das eine nur Generation 2 ist und das andere Generation 3.
Wisst ihr, was ich gerade dachte, was eigentlich interessant wäre?
Was wäre, wenn die Kühlung jetzt wirklich, wirklich, wirklich gut wäre?
Das kommen wir gleich.
Ich werde erst mal gucken, was das Ding kostet.
Konfigurieren und bestellen.
Okay, auf geht's.
Okay, die Base-Variante.
Okay, die Base-Variante jetzt konfigurieren.
Mal gucken, was das kostet.
Kann nichts machen.
Grafikkarte.
Ja, lassen wir mal.
Ich will eigentlich nur mal CPUs gucken.
Excellent.
16G RAM sollten schon sein.
SSD 500, 500G darf es schon sein.
Geht eigentlich preislich.
Komm, hier, Terabyte macht es jetzt anders aus.
WLAN ist okay, kann Standard bleiben.
Beleuchtet Tastatur, braucht kein Mensch.
Man kann die Wärmeleitpaste im Bestellprozess auswählen.
Und es gibt nur eine.
Ach so, RAM.
Ne, wir brauchen schnelleren RAM, Leute.
Wir brauchen den gleichen.
Das ist der gleiche RAM, den ich auch im Desktop habe.
Brauchen wir.
So.
Betriebssystem kann ich selbst installieren.
Permanent.
Garantie.
Basic.
Kein Logo.
Kein Logo kostet extra.
Also, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Das geht.
Das ist wirklich in Ordnung.
Das ist echt in Ordnung.
Was kostet das?
Ich meine, das geht.
Ich habe jetzt auch gedacht, das Ding kostet 5K oder so.
Es ist halt kein richtiger Laptop.
Also, man kann das nicht wirklich lange mobil verwenden.
Garantiert nicht.
Wofür man das braucht, ist mir auch relativ egal.
Weil ich würde mir einfach einen Desktop hinstellen.
Wie wäre die Leistung der CPU dann?
Ja, hau Flüssigstickstoff drauf.
Da ist es doch praktisch, dass wir einen vollwertigen HDMI-Anschluss hinten dran haben.
Hab das Teil zugeklappt, umgedreht, Monitor angeschlossen und dann würde ich sagen, Flüssigstickstoff-Kühler drauf.
Los geht's.
Stand da was zum Gewicht?
Gute Frage.
Das gucken wir gerade noch mal.
Gucken, was da Kram wiegt.
Gucken wir mal, was da Kram wiegt.
Ähm.
Steht da irgendwie was Gewicht?
Nicht wirklich, ne?
2,6 Kilo.
Ein bisschen was zu schleppen hat man, aber das geht auch.
Für das, was es ist, ist es vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ah, yes.
Eine Runde Flüssigstickstoff drauf.
Der Moment, wenn sich selbst die Katze fragt, was zur Hölle ich hier gerade mache.
Das sieht doch schon mal vernünftig aus.
Knapp über 0 Grad.
Übrigens senkt sich natürlich auch die Leistungsaufnahme der CPU, nur weil sie kalt ist und dementsprechend sollte das schon in mehr Leistung resultieren.
Das probieren wir direkt mal aus.
So gefällt mir das schon eher.
8000 Punkte.
Das geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung.
Das Coole ist übrigens, dass die Lüfter jetzt gar nicht mehr laufen, weil CPU-Kühler hat minus 25 Grad hier.
Das ist alles wirklich sehr, sehr kalt.
Ich würde sagen knapp am Gefrierpunkt.
Ja.
Der Wärmeübertrag mit Heatpipes ist jetzt natürlich nicht so gut.
Heatpipes leiten die Wärme nicht so effizient nach unten zur CPU runter.
Hilft aber auf jeden Fall, hat man schon gesehen.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie weit wir noch kommen.
Sehr, sehr geil.
Über 9000 Punkte und damit über dem normalen Wert eines 359X, was man in einem Desktop-PC hat.
Also 9200 Punkte im Laptop.
Wirklich absolut krank.
Gut.
Auf jeden Fall.
Keiner mit Flüssig-Steckdorfer nebenbei.
95 bzw. 130 Amperestellen.
Und der Kühler lief hier ganz geschmeidig die ganze Zeit.
Circa minus 35, vorhin sogar minus 40 Grad Celsius.
Man sieht jetzt nach einiger Zeit auch, wie sich hier überall unten an den Heatpipes schön Eis gebildet hat.
Und wir hören jetzt auch auf, weil ich will das Teil nicht kaputt machen.
Da würde sich XMG sicherlich nicht drüber freuen.
Aber sehr, sehr cool, was man so machen kann.
Und dass ein Mainboard in einem Notebook, das jetzt ja nicht unbedingt für die absolut besten Spannungswanderer berühmt ist normalerweise, auch sowas kann.
Das heißt, wenn man hier eine extrem krasse Kühlung hat, dann kann so ein Notebook problemlos die CPU dauerhaft mit 4,2 GHz versorgen.
Bei 16 Kernen.
An dieser Stelle sind wir jetzt auch durch mit dem XMG Apex 15.
Weil es geht.
Sehr, sehr cool.
Einfach weil es geht.
So eine dauerflüssige Stickstofflösung wäre halt nice.
Weiß nicht, ob das so nice wäre.
Musste ja laufen neuen flüssigen Stickstoff holen.
Weiß nicht, was kostet sowas?
Was kauft man sich dafür?
Was kauf ich mir dafür, wenn ich sowas hätte?
Sowas?
Nee, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Gasepartner.de
Supercold.
Was es nicht alles, ja, so zu kaufen gibt.
Favorite Procuring Language?
Garantiert nicht Java und PHP.
Paper Please.
What the fuck.
Das is ein typisches Exclusivideo, Alter.
Das is ein typisches Exclusivvideo, Alter.
Das is ein typisches Exclusivchatvideo.
Die guckt aber auch.
Irgendwie ein bisschen mitgenommen.
Hab' ja schon geguckt.
Almost Relive.
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie bei ihm Relive aussieht, aber bei mir hat es weniger Blöcke.
Linus Monitor Upgrade schon gesehen.
Nee.
Welches? Ja das da. Okay, aber das können wir nochmal gucken. Der Bauer hat ein neues Video
hochgeladen. Ja, macht er öfters. Okay, gucken wir mal.
Das ist übersteuert. Ja, kann ich mich mit identifizieren.
Ultraweit.
Warum hat er ein Tesla-Logo auf seiner Tür?
World of Warships.
Das könnte ein bisschen eng werden, ja.
Also wenn das jetzt ein Apple-Monitor-Stand war, dann kostet der auch 2.000 Euro.
Der Monitor ist definitiv teurer als das Notebook, was wir uns davor angeguckt haben.
Und er ist von den ersten 3440x1440 Ultraweit.
Und weil der noch größer ist, ist er noch 1440 Pixel hoch, aber er ist tatsächlich 5120 Pixel
weit.
Also ist er quasi das Gleiche wie 5K, außer er ist ein halbes Stück weiter unten.
Das gibt dir effektiv die Resolution und die Gegend der 2 27-Inch-1440-P-Monitore von
Seite zu Seite.
Mit keinem Bezel drüben.
Das ist wahr.
Das ist ein guter Bezug.
Es kommt mir an, dass ich den Stand nicht benötigen muss.
Oh, ich habe meinen Gesicht getäuscht.
Zeit für Sanierung.
Du hast ihn schon getäuscht, es ist zu spät.
Und ich könnte ihn noch mal getäuschen, also werde ich ihn sanieren.
Mann, diese Sachen sind Biesten.
Es ist wirklich schön, dass die meisten kurven Monitore heute
immer noch eine Standard-Vase-Version eintragen,
weil es vor einiger Zeit so war,
dass man spezielle Adapteure bekommen musste,
die man kaufen musste,
wenn man sie überhaupt finden konnte.
Und es ist einfach zu sagen, kurve Monitore sind dumm.
Warum kriegst du nicht nur einen nicht-kurven Monitore?
Aber das Ding ist, wenn etwas so breit ist,
macht die Kurve tatsächlich eine Unterschiede.
Es hilft also bei jedem Farbschiff, den man bekommt.
Ich meine, es ist ein IPS-Panel, also wird es nicht viel sein.
Aber du wirst ein bisschen bekommen.
Und es macht auch ein bisschen mehr
natürlicher, wenn du direkt auf das Display schaust,
auch wenn du deinen Kopf schaltest, was du tun wirst.
Das ist wirklich schwer, ich muss das hier runterlegen.
Ah!
Keiner von diesen hat so weit eine Überraschung gemacht.
Das ist genau das, was ich erwartet habe.
Der X-Factor ist der Vivo-Monitor-Tabelland.
Er ist für 27 Inch auf dem Topf gestattet.
Das sind im Grunde 27, aber zwei von ihnen.
So, solange hier ihre Gewichtsversorgung
einen Buffer in sich baut, denke ich,
sind wir in Ordnung.
Nuts down.
Woher kommt das?
Darauf CSGO 4 zu 3.
Das wäre massive.
High IQ-Play.
Die geschlossenen sind hier.
Also, falls du es nicht ausbauen möchtest,
aber dann denkst du, dass du es mit ...
Weißt du was, ich schaue mir die Instruktionen an.
Oh, ich habe einen Schritt verpasst.
Ich sehe keinen offiziellen Weg,
die Platte aus dem Mont zu entfernen.
Also, ja, ich denke, es wäre wirklich einfacher,
wenn ich die Platte aus dem Mont aufnehme.
Und dann wieder, vielleicht nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, es wird so schwer,
wenn ich das tue.
Es scheint nicht wirklich ein Industriestandard zu sein,
wer die Schrauben für ein Vesamo bietet.
Hier hat LG die Schrauben eingeführt,
aber ich habe viele Monitore gesehen,
die die Schrauben nicht eingeführt haben.
Ich werde LGs Schrauben benutzen.
Sie sind schwarz und passen.
Oh, ich habe die Wascher vergessen.
Das ist egal.
Wir werden die Wascher anziehen.
Okay.
Hier.
Etwa 30 Kilo.
Au, mein Finger.
Weißt du, vielleicht muss etwas gesagt werden
für Apples 1.000-Dollar-Stand.
Ich mache das hier stärker.
Okay.
Oh, Junge.
Franky ist so hart,
er wird sich schüren.
Die Amis sind noch die Letzten,
die mit ihren komischen Ounces, Inches und Redones rummachen.
Sogar die Engländer haben es langsam geschafft.
Bei normalen Einheiten anzukommen.
Oh.
I think it's holding.
Wow, that was an uncomfortable amount of pressure.
Time for the tricky part now.
So long there, buddy.
Nice knowing you.
Wow, where am I going to put my webcam?
Oh, okay.
Aber in Kanada sollten die doch erst recht ordentliche Einheiten haben.
This time I'm going to crank this mount while it's easy to get up,
because we are way over the rated weight.
How are you going to do that?
You need two people, I feel.
No, I got this.
Don't worry.
Oh, my God.
Es ist ein bisschen unhandlich, habe ich das Gefühl.
Yeah, that's what she said.
Oh.
Oh, no.
The plastic insert is coming out,
but it's on there too much to easily get it off now.
Hopefully I don't get guillotined here.
Der wollte gerade sagen, gleich ist der Kopf ab.
Gleich ist der Kopf ab, Alter.
Okay, that's heavy.
Maybe that's our thumbnail.
Okay, come on.
Okay.
Both of the plastic inserts came out.
Ich meine, ihr könnt es auf die Erde stellen,
dann müssten wir es halt danach hochheben.
They suck and they're bad and I hate them.
Now they're back in there, but what keeps them in there?
I don't know.
Do you need help?
No, I'm good.
I got this.
Look, the people paid good money to watch me struggle.
Don't worry about it.
It's fine.
The table is flexing a lot.
Oh, I went back.
Are you okay?
If you need to take a break, you should take a break.
And if we need to switch to a lighter camera,
we should switch to a lighter camera.
I'm fine.
Dennis.
Making fine adjustments to this is not going to be possible.
Oh, come on.
Stop.
No.
What are you stuck on?
I'm getting my fingers crushed.
Auf der Erde wird es so einfach gewesen.
That's going on easy.
Are they on there properly?
Es sieht ein bisschen schlecht aus.
Do they look like they're on there properly?
I thought you were going to say, like, we're done.
No.
Jake said, even for his 34ers, he had to, like,
crank the bejesus out of these.
Ow.
That just bruised my palm.
Wait, what?
What is it even hitting?
Okay, well, that's progress.
Hey, credits to LG for the packing material for this monitor.
And if you think this looks horrible,
you should have seen what Jake had to do for 16K Gaming.
That was 16 monitors.
I think the whole stand is leaning forward.
I think the whole desk is leaning forward.
Haha.
Can we switch to a lighter camera?
It's not on right.
We're recording.
So, we're down to our fifth string camera operator.
Don't move anything heavy.
And go fill out the f***ing form.
Dennis.
He hurt his back.
He was laughing at me.
That's why, that's how he did it.
Oh, yeah.
So, if you guys notice, the camera's a little...
Wow!
Yeah, sorry, guys.
That's Riley.
He's helping us out here.
Ja, mir wäre es auch ein bisschen zu viel, Monitor, ehrlich gesagt.
I'm going to run my display port and power cables first,
because this is going to be challenging.
I didn't cut an entry slip for a second monitor here.
Ow!
Oh, man.
Riddle me this, Riley.
Should I go with them not quite butted together,
but with the top one angled down at me a little bit,
even though that means a slightly bigger gap here?
I mean, I feel like you probably should angle it down a bit, eh?
Die Frage ist nur eher, was will er da drauf alles, alles einplätten, eh?
Ich habe zwei Monitore, zwei, 22, drei, ein, ein, ein,
ein 22- und 23-Zoll-Monitor.
Das reicht.
I'm going to butt them up together.
Tightness, that's my specialty.
That's what I like, settling.
It'll do.
You need help.
No, I can move it.
Don't move anything heavy.
Oh, God, that's heavy.
Okay.
Was wiegt denn das, hä?
50 Kilo?
Was wird denn das wohl wiegen?
Oh.
You want me to move the keyboard?
Hopefully it won't scratch the glass.
No, no, I got this, I got this, I got this.
Oh, oh, just a little.
The people paid good money to see me struggle.
And right now they can't see me,
because I'm behind the monitor.
Oh!
I assure you, the struggle is real.
50 Kilo, okay.
I think they just need to, like that.
There's a chance it's still aligned.
Gleich bricht, gleich bricht das Glas.
Oh, oh, that's good.
That's where the DP goes in.
This is where the second DP goes in.
I can't get behind it to lift it, you know?
This is where you could almost need, use help.
Wie groß sind unsere Monitore auf der Arbeit?
Ich glaube, 32 Zoll curved 4K.
On the way back.
Yeah, you know, it held 50% more than the rated weight.
Wide screen.
You know what's funny is,
I believe LG actually moved the nipple
from the bottom here to over here
in case of installations like this.
And I laughed at them.
At CES, I laughed at them.
I was like, nobody's gonna do that.
Now all I need to do is get all my windows arranged.
Nee, die haben nur 60 Hertz.
Keine 144 Hertz auf der Arbeit.
Window management programs that allow you
to split your screens up into many more zones
than the normal windows.
Ja, das Fenster da hinten braucht er wirklich nicht.
Einfach weißen Hintergrund machen, easy Licht.
Or Aerosnap or whatever they call it now,
where you just kind of go like that.
But in the meantime,
this is where I kind of expect things to land.
So I want something for my Microsoft Teams chat.
Yes, we use Microsoft Teams.
No, it's not perfect.
But well, we're using it.
Here, whatever I'm currently writing,
or reviewing someone else,
you know, a web browser
for maybe I'm doing some research
or browsing the forum
to see what people are saying over there.
Here, where I can go through all of our video ideas.
This is a much older version of this sheet
that I can show you guys,
because it's all stuff that we did ages ago.
And then up here.
This is the big one.
Ach, das ist gar kein Hintergrund.
Being able to stretch out Trello here
so that I can see every stage of the production queue
and all the assignments.
I can't show you the writer's ones,
because there's a lot of projects
that we haven't released yet.
Dafür braucht er so...
The fuck?
Der Hälfte davon ist gar nicht verwendet.
Everyone's supposed to be working on all at once.
The RevMon Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, huge sub.
Organize things into it.
Without moving back and forth
between different browser windows
and stuff like that.
Really very excited about this.
I'm not 100% sure on the ergonomics.
Could I have just put a TV on my desk?
Ich frag mich, was machst du?
Genau, FlowBob, das hab ich auch gefragt.
Wenn du dich fragst, wo ist die Maus?
Wo findest du die Maus wieder?
Erst mal eine halbe Stunde Display absuchen.
Yes.
Gut, man könnte sich so einen Maushighlighter installieren.
Dann drückt man eine Taste
und dann zeigt es dir, wo die Maus ist.
Also so was hier.
Auf welchem Knopf hatte ich das nochmal?
Auf welchem Knopf hatte ich den Maushighlighter?
C, hier.
Ui.
So was bräuchte man dann.
Da ist die Maus.
Oder Mauszeiger vergrößern.
But damn it!
This is Linus Tech Tips.
It's not how we do things around here.
Here, we mount our webcams.
Where?
I'm gonna end up with the solution
from all those laptops.
You pointed up the nose.
No!
Oh, da haben wir auch ein paar Leute bei uns.
Bei denen kannst du gefühlt in die Nase reingucken,
weil sie die Kamera so weit unten stehen haben.
It would be awful.
Das ist auch, wenn du an irgendeiner Teamsbesprechung
bei uns bist, die Leute, entweder haben sie gar keine Kamera
und wenn sie die Kamera haben, dann ist die
genauso schlecht platziert,
wie sich ihr Mikrofonsound anhört.
... is a free-to-play strategy action game
that someone referred to as the thinking person.
Aber es ist immer noch unglaublich,
wie jetzt nach fast einer Woche,
fast einem Monat Homeoffice,
die Leute immer noch nicht ihr Audio-Setup
und ihr Video-Setup auf die Reihe gekriegt haben.
Hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung,
wie man in Teams
die Audio-Settings von OBS reinbekommt
oder die Möglichkeit in Teams
Audio-Plugins zu laden?
Ich würde nämlich beispielsweise gerne
auch ein bisschen, auch ein bisschen,
Messer und Noisegate in Teams anmachen.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit?
Kann Teams VST-Plugins?
Geht so was vielleicht?
Nee.
Nee, nee, nee, nicht VST.
Heißt das nicht VST?
Doch, oder? VST.
Oh ja, ich könnte natürlich auch
so Virtual-Audio-Cable-Gedöns machen.
Ja, das würde funktionieren.
Das könnte ich tatsächlich machen, ja.
Am liebsten wäre mir es ja,
dass ich OBS-Settings einfach verwenden könnte.
Da hätte ich Angst, dass er mir in den Finger beißt.
Oh, guck mal, 720p ist nicht mehr HD bei YouTube.
Ja, mein Audio-Interface könnte das,
aber ich habe das Audio-Interface ja nicht
an meinem Rechner hier dran, sondern an dem anderen.
Ich glaube, das tut weh, wenn der dir in den Finger beißt.
Wahrscheinlich muss er seine USB-Kabel
auch öfters mal ersetzen.
Elite Light, Easy, nee, Easy Elite,
das, nee, Easy Light, WTF,
jetzt frage ich den Namen irgendwann mal.
Das mache ich auch so.
Ich verwende aktuell auch mein Smartphone
für die Webcam bei Teams und Mikro vom Desktop.
Das mache ich aktuell auch so.
Wie verwendest du dein Smartphone als Webcam?
Einfach Teams drauf installiert
und dann joine ich in die Teams-Besprechung,
rein mit Voice und mute mich auf dem Smartphone
und verwende vom Desktop aus das Headset.
Das funktioniert.
Bisschen asynchron, aber wen juckt's?
Muss mal gucken, wie ich, wie ich
mein, ähm, Kompressor-Settings in OBS kriege.
Dann klingt's noch besser.
Die Leute freuen sich ja schon immer,
wenn man ordentliche Audioqualität hat im Teams.
Was ist das?
Another interesting update.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, um was es geht.
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Spiel?
CSGO has gotten another big update.
Ah, CSGO, okay.
Das hätte ich jetzt so, hätte ich jetzt so,
das hätte ich jetzt so nicht erkannt,
dass das CS ist an der Vorschau.
Seit wann sind die Button links?
Das kommt auf die Auflösung und das Zoom-Level an.
Guck mal, wenn ich so auf normale, normale Größe stelle,
dann ist es auch hier normal,
aber wenn man es auf 100, was weiß ich, 150 oder so,
dann sieht das so aus.
Ich hab das überall.
Die Leute fragen mich teilweise immer schon auf der Arbeit.
Max, siehst du schlecht?
Ähm, ich weiß gar nicht, wie die auf die Idee kommen.
Bloß, weil man die Schriftgröße so einstellt,
dass es angenehm zu lesen ist.
Habt ihr auch dieses Grundrauschen bei euren Teamsitzungen?
Ich glaube, das ist, ich hab das Gefühl,
dass es wie bei Skype ist,
dass das Grundrauschen von Microsoft reingemacht wird,
dass man hört, die Leute sind noch da.
Das kommt gar nicht vom Mikro.
High IQ Microsoft Audio Processing.
Der Rest nicht, okay.
Ja, ob ich's hab, weiß ich nicht.
Ich hör mich ja selbst in Teams nicht.
Generell ist Teams ziemlich unpolished, das Produkt, ja.
Also Teams ist schon ein bisschen unfertig an vielen Stellen
und auch nicht gut durchdacht.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Vorschau der Kamera
überhaupt nicht das widerspiegelt,
was andere Leute sehen.
Ich meine, the fuck?
Wozu hab ich da eine Vorschau?
Gut, Leute, ich hab übelst Hunger und ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Immer noch besser als WebEx.
Ja gut, WebEx ist ja auch echt, naja, Cisco-Zeug.
Unnötig überkompliziertes Cisco-Zeug.
Das Beste an Teams ist, dass ein Meme-Generator eingebaut ist.
Heute neues Video.
Ja, ich hab's vor.
Ich wollte heute das Valorant Video machen,
Artichit.
Gucken, ob ich das noch hinkrieg.
Custom-E-Modes fehlen.
Ja, da wird's Zeit mal, dass Microsoft wieder herkommt.
Also, Leute, lasst euch nicht anstecken.
Wir sehen uns dann die Woche.
Irgendwann.
Wenn ihr noch einen freien Prime-Sub habt,
ich würd mich natürlich sehr drüber freuen,
über noch mehr High-IQ-Subscribers.
Wisst ihr, wenn ihr einen Prime-Account habt,
könnt ihr einmal im Monat kostenlos sammeln.
Einen Streamer eurer Wahl.
Ja, ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Ich bin irgendwann die Woche wieder da.
Primdom.
Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
EasyClap.
Ab und zu ein bisschen Sellout zahlt sich aus.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ähm.
Ja, was gibt's sonst noch zu sagen?
Ich guck mal, ob wir die Sache weiterprogrammieren on Stream,
die wir gestern angefangen haben.
Weil ich wurde jetzt ja schon öfters gefragt,
ob's noch wieder ein bisschen mehr Programmier-Streams gibt.
Ich hab jetzt relativ wenig Programmier-Streams
in letzter Zeit gemacht.
Wir haben uns eher ein bisschen Linux-Zeug angeguckt,
rumgebastelt, aber programmiert haben wir selten.
Machen wir vielleicht wieder.
Wobei ich dann C++ programmieren muss.
Wir sehen uns auf jeden Fall irgendwann die Woche.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
CU.